une production du studio sfr néo sans
filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut avec nos invités baptiste
super content avec madame plantes y ait
cette semaine le podcast est sponsorisé
par planethoster lundi est une société
d'hébergement web nous a fait pour ses
collaborations le on a migré notre site
web va être construit maintenant est
hébergé par résoudre ça s'est fait
tellement facilement
c'est fou en fait j'en reviens pas de
l'expérience client il est le support
technique qui offrent toutefois
technique 24 heures sur 24
décret message est très pratiquement
passé ça je voulais passer des messages
en plus de l'anus toile c'est tout qui
se créent deux tubes puis je vais passer
des messages qui comme un peu mieux la
nuit quelqu'un qui dit amadou il
faudrait qu'ils m'envoient telles
informations
ils te répondent rapidement il ya même
pris contrôle de mon ordi de 30 ans ne
pliaient tout régler ce fait que ça
c'est ce pas facile face si vous voulez
vous partir un site web que vous soyez
un particulier quelque chose de vraiment
simple ou une grosse entreprise qui a
besoin d'un site web très complexe les
deux sont possibles puissent vraiment
dans la facilité il ya plusieurs
promotions intéressantes si vous
l'immigré justement des données mettant
vous êtes à berger par une autre société
d'hébergement piqué vous aimez pas ce
fait migrer vers planète roster vous
avez la migration gratuite puis un
premier mois gratuit
si vous êtes une organisation sans but
lucratif 25 % de rabais pour vous alors
plus belle sa foi comme ce donc aussi
différents paliers comme c'est en tout
si vous êtes une petite entreprise une
grosse entreprise ou juste une personne
qui veut se faire un blog quoi que ce
soit planètes rocheuses puis on a un
code promo aussi pleins d'eau sur tout à
fait comme quoi mot cph réunion sans
résignons filtre s'arrête dans les
descriptions des vidéos vous avez 25 %
de rabais sur sur vos achats de services
ou de produits avec planète golf etc
allez voir c'est toujours le fun si vous
encourager les compagnies qui nous
encouragent nous permet de nous de
continuer à faire ce conflit vous
connaissez comment la roue tourne
sinon cette semaine au sans fil qu'on a
reçu pour la deuxième fois
olivier bernard donc le grand retour du
pharmacien
on avait très hâte de tourner ce pack à
cela parce que le premier pas de casse
avec olivier ça m'avait vraiment été un
conte avait adoré je pense que vous vous
lavez mais aussi cette fois ci est
revenue pour parler de nouveaux sujets
sur lesquels ils s'intéressent notamment
l'arrivée massive de produits
alternatifs à la viande
donc vous avez sûrement entendu parler
du bien aux mythes qui est un peu
partout olivier s'y pencher beaucoup lui
même est un végétarien flexitariens
appelons ça comme ça mais s'intéresse
surtout à tous les lobbys derrière ce
puits cette question-là des lobbys nous
a permis après ceux de détendre la
discussion vers d'autres sujets la
contreverse entre autres autour de
l'injection de vitamine c qui je crois
que la situation c'est que ça servirait
à réduire les effets de la
chimiothérapie puis c'est controversé
puis lui décrit sous beaucoup critiqué
le fait qu avait pas vraiment de base
scientifique à danser dans une
controverse est sorti dans les médias il
s'est pas beaucoup ouvert sur le sujet
en entrevue au vrai que c'est la
première fois qu'ils venaient en parler
sérieusement douter beaucoup la vitamine
c gates
puis on a parlé d'une clause à faire que
lui est vraiment intéressant à chaque
fois à chaque fois qu'on le rencontre
puis un homme passionnant à écouter en
podcast en ce moment vous nous écoutez
sûrement sur youtube sur balles à dos
sur spotify sur google play peu importe
où est ce que vous écoutez c'est
extrêmement important pour nous si vous
abonner à toutes nos chaînes
si vous laissez des commentaires si vous
laissez un rating optimalement de cinq
étoiles ou un top job si vous êtes sur
youtube
ça fait son bout de chemin ça permet
au studio studio sa promo sans filtre de
contenu à grossir et par la bande le
studio sfc on n'a pas fait de charlotte
dernièrement aux autres packs asturies
cf mais si vous avez l'occasion d'aller
écouter les podcasts de jay du stand
j'ai dit en discutant des excellentes
conversation ou encore si vous
intéressez à la scène du hip hop du rap
et du hip hop et aussi à la culture tout
entourant le cannabis et son utilisation
récréative
allez voir le terme le job avec adamo
ces deux podcasts qu'on produit va avoir
d'autres podcast très prochainement sur
le sans filtre on est déjà en train de
tourner d'autres projets c'est super
intéressant puisqu'on est content que
vous soyez là avec nous dans ce projet
là au début de notre deuxième année du
centenaire cast fait que sans plus
attendre on vous laisse avec olivier bon
écoute bon podcast
[Musique]
olivier pour la deuxième fois à merci
d'être là ça fait tellement plaisir là
j'ai tellement de fans la première fois
que je venu révéler la nuit j'avais des
gros seins
comment ça va ce temps-ci de ces restes
pas bien ouais ouais vraiment vraiment
je pense à ce pas belle et ayant plus
surviennent vacances le titan voyage
wild en vacances avec ma blonde on en
prend elle était honnêtement c'est ma
saison où je peux son écriture au fait
que ce capable d'être of ouais ouais
t'es capable de notre offre comme
absolument absolument je suis capable
qualité c'est bon mais je suis comme
tout le monde c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné des fois je me mets à
travailler pour le pin pieroni je me
rends plus compte que je travaille trop
puis le match et la boue apps mais
jusqu'à pas demeurer ajuster ses
finances
c'est ça l'important une personne qui
est parfait mais j'ai quand même à nous
faire un bois où le droit de prendre du
temps les mots exacts jeu là dedans
résultat les guetteurs un peu pour un
prochain livre saison 4 de la série télé
dans le temps moins exacts eu beaucoup
en écriture pour ce que j'écris toutes
les scénarios jsk est rude et animiste
mais ça c'est pas juste moi qui fais le
travail des gars qui s'appelle et
satirique le pieux ils écrivent la
majorité des dieux qui écrit des
sketches et écrivent beaucoup des
dessins animés sur moi c'est plus
classique contenu en tant que tel le
fixe et la recherche ont froid et c'est
la recherche c'est de décrire les
structures de tout les épisodes qui joue
interviews et qu'est ce que je fais
c'est quoi les recherches que je fais et
que cette erreur et ça c'est très très
lentement c'est sûr ça va être le fun
par exemple ben moi c'est moi j'ai très
peu là dessus de moi j'étais un
solitaire à la barbe noire et que je
travaille très bien tout seul fait qu
est chez nous familles recherchent
famille structure mais scénario m'a
demandé qu'est ce que je fais est une
mode pour moi si je suis dans mon
élément est à prendre toutes les sujets
qui intéressent les anciens série
l'aquifère le pharmacien en général
pour moi c'est ma formation continue
mais ces scènes dans le sens où je
tenterai de faire des recherches sur les
choses qui intéressent le monde parce
que moi c'est je veux parler des sujets
qui rejoint tout le monde et que ça
m'oblige à me mettre à jour constamment
surprenant faire la file et je me mets
pas à jour sur les mêmes choses que
mettons les autres pharmaciens qui comme
moi quand je rencontre d'autres massifs
comme chute chez des fois le ch comme
déjà calé complètement et totalement la
dz des affaires d'assurances ou des
choses comme ça le suit elle
changeant paire de bottes mais en même
temps moi c'est le moal aspic qui me
reste c'est l'aspect vraiment lennik
l'aspect la santé en général faculty ça
devient plus complémentaires tout se
passe quand il parle d'un sujet mais
temps sec et chaud fera un épisode sur
tel sujet c'est quoi ton niveau d
expertise de sujets le avant de
commenter des recherches et sérieux ça
peut varier de très bonne expertise à je
sais rien pantoute qui aurait vraiment
vraiment vraiment si comme je vous donne
un exemple la saison 3 j'ai fait un
épisode sur les vitamines donc les
suppléments de vitamines et minéraux et
tout c'est un sujet que je connais comme
le fond de ma poche s'est fait que j'ai
commencé l'épisode qui déjà je savais
tout autre lotis moi j'ai quand même
fait la job à nice c'est à dire que je
me suis posé les bonnes questions qui
reflètent la recherche documentaire et
de suggérer manqué juste à les voires
des experts mais c'est ultimement le
sujet je le connaissais je savais qu est
ce que ça donnerait mais j'ai fait aussi
un épisode sur l'accouchement et je
connais rien la vie je n'ai pas d'enfant
factice je suis parti tellement loin
puis honnêtement ce que je pensais au
début de avant de faire l'épisode à la
fin j'ai quasiment inchangé au total et
beaucoup de thé c'est ma question c'est
est souvent surpris des conclusions
auxquelles tard et vous avez à peu près
la moitié des épisodes jeudi ac j'ai des
bonnes surprises - woippy l'autre moitié
des épisodes ça va dans le sens que ce
que je m'attendais c'est fake c'est
moitié moitié à peu près personne
capable de surprendre dans les sujets
qui connaît pas ses armes en tant que
l'un des sujets que tu penses cadre est
relatif et grimsey que j'avais pas vu de
cette façon là c'est en fait j'étais je
tenais un congrès scientifique il ya pas
longtemps il ya manier un coq geste est
une conférence sur la vaccination qui
est un coach pour qu'ils lèvent la main
se pose la question parce qu'ils y
aillent j'ai pas vraiment une question
mais j'ai plus un commentaire de débat
émotionnel que je veux partager des
motifs non plus ce qui veut dire il dit
je trouve sur hbo dans notre communauté
comme est ce qu'on est capable de
changer d'idée sur des sujets quand les
preuves scientifiques vont dans une
direction quelconque puis qu'on est prêt
à les suivre
il dit moi je trouve qu'une beauté la
vda c'est de pouvoir dire nous on est
sûr de telles affaires au shit on avait
complètement pas tenu compte de la feria
des nouvelles données ok on change
d'idée là dessus un épicier raison
de quoi de super bowl a peut-être si
j'avais dit ce que j'avais cette diction
l'a dernièrement avec marvel plus qui
mais c'était au sujet au sujet de la
science vu comme comme de quoi un
scientifique se base sur des faits au
moment où est ce qu ont les yeux c'est
au moment où est ce que la recherche est
faite puis claude effet pour l'instant
la science dissociant un jour les faits
contredisent ces faits là qu'on avait le
scientifique va être capable d'admettre
que la science est rendue l'autre ouais
puis c'est celle à l'espèce de link qui
se joue entre la science et l'art et les
sciences la grille croyances si on veut
exactement puis ça c'est une croyance
veut y adhérer même si les fêtes prouve
le contraire
mais le scientifique rigoureux va
changer d'avis parce que par définition
il doit coller son opinion sur la
science exacte le scientifique rigoureux
mais c'est ce que les scientifiques
c'est des personnes faillible comme
c'est pas tout le monde qui rigoureux
bah c'est à dire que les six points qui
sont pas tous rigoureux je pense qu'ils
sont tous rigoureuse dans sa tête ce
qu'ils font mais des fois ci on peut
tous sur un moment donné être victimes
de nos propres biais de nos propre
idéologie il y en a dix scientifiques un
moment donné ils finissent par pu voir
vraiment l'air dans leurs affaires puis
ils partent dans un espèce de sheer le
cas pas de bon sens y en a plein comme
ça mais mais mais j'ose croire que la
vaste majorité des scientifiques
effectivement c'est des gens qui sont
prêts a complètement changé leur fusil
d'épaulé
si les preuves sont là puis il ya
vraiment quelque chose que je trouve le
fort note ccc c'est vraiment de force je
pense dans les rues et aux fesses que
c'est quoi les mettons l'exemple le plus
frappant que toi tu es arrivé par
rapport à ça et c'est un moment qui se
rappelle d'abord d'avoir eu un genre de
déclic de faire ok ce que je disais ce
que je croyais était complètement dans
le champ gauche alors que c'est à droite
que ça s'en aller
virage à 180 comme ce je ne sais pas si
c'est à ce point là mais en fait je te
dirais que tout ce qui est par rapport à
l'alimentation vg en général
je connais tu m'as j'ai eu des gros
changement par rapport à ce que je pense
que ça venait d'un manque de
connaissance on avait plus par la
dernière fois est ce que est ce que
quelqu'un aussi cartésien qui me semble
l'être
corrigez moi si je me trompe dans la
prochaine affirmation sensiblement vécu
ce mois ma copine m'a influence
énormément à poser certaines questions
que je me serais jamais posée avant par
rapport à l'alimentation végétale est ce
que pour toi ce questionnement lait
venus avec avec india buisson son amour
pour les animaux pour la façon avec
laquelle la voyait cette question-là
expliqué qu'elle est au delà de l'aide
au delà de la science si on veut qu'ils
étaient plus cotés d'affectif mais en
fait c'est sûr que à mon influence et au
même titre que je les influences riches
je pense qu'on signe influencé
mutuellement mais pas sur les mêmes
affaires c'est à dire que moi quand j'ai
rencontré india la base était à manger
presque pas de viande puis honnêtement
je lis mme influencer négativement mais
je leur influence les dans la mesure où
moi j'étais un gros mangeur de viande
puis je pense que j en ai fait manger
plus et involontaire et elle je pense
que hameau peut-être inculquer je te
dirai justement ciel si tu étais plus
végétarienne donc elles avaient tendance
à manger des affaires que moi j'étais
vraiment pas habitué beaucoup de
légumineuses entre autres des choses
comme ça ou six pieds aussi une
passionnée d d d animaux a dit je pense
qu'elle la cause un peu animal à le tout
le temps eu un an née à lac est parti
sans nécessairement tout savoir
- l'eau gelée influencé par contre c'est
au niveau 7 le niveau plus scientifique
c'est à dire que moi avant je me dis ben
je je je le sais qu'il faut manger il
plaint de végétaux ainsi tout le temps
sur le g10 depuis que j'ai commencé mes
métiers quand j'ai commencé à voir des
bons arguments ben là je lis et des
ailes a comme aussi et qui a pas de
réviser certaines impressions certaines
croyances qui à l'évidence a peut-être
fait que je pense qu'on s'est beaucoup
c'était vraiment donnant donnant
puis sur toi tu attends ta pensée par
rapport à ça a changé
mais quand quand a commencé à avoir les
bonnes informations
quand on s'est écrit un peu pour savoir
de quoi on allait parler aujourd'hui
c'était un des sujets que je trouvais en
fait j'avais l'intention de l'aborder
avec toi même proposé l'espèce de boom
dans la nourriture végétale avec iron
mines et autres
je lisais c'est les produits et ses 800
% d'augmentation
les produits des neuf de simulation de
viande lait de fusion les produits vegan
de 800 % au québec si ces massifs le
sien réellement un changement de
paradigme claire totalement pis toi le
point que tu as menée dans ce que tu
m'écrivait c'était de voir la réaction
de certains lobbys à ce changement le
plus tu ne mets le lobby la viande
évidemment oui mais aussi le lobby bio
pro bio à tripoli pendant toute la vie
le lobby sans ogm
ouais mais ça c'est curieux parce qu'on
a on on y pense comme pas le lobby
robillot il se met à chercher sur ce pic
mais qu'est-ce qui c'est quoi la
problématique dans tout ça est que super
intéressant dans le fond c'est que moi
ce qui me fascine dans l'espèce de baume
végétales comme tu dis c'est à quel
point ça polarise finalement la
population il ya des réactions extrêmes
par rapport à un soir on est en droit de
se demander d'où vient cette
polarisation laisse que peu de groupes
qui finalement augmente la polarisation
qui vont finalement essayé de créer le
monde dans un sens ou dans l'autre
ok via autant des groupes qui sont pros
végétales et des groupes sont en tissu
végétal
les deux sont pas mal extrêmes le fallu
il y en a vraiment des forces dans les
deux directions
le lobby par exemple du biopic anti ogm
en ce moment on le voit et il traite pas
sur le boom végétal pourquoi pour
plusieurs raisons
l'alimentation bio qui ont besoin des
animaux sains
parce que c'est quoi qui utilise comme
fertilisant principal féminin
ils ont besoin des quantités de fumier
qui sont absolument massif des quantités
fumées qui proviennent de l'industrie
bah oui c'est vraiment entend donc c'est
sûr que ils sont pas nécessairement
compte mais c'est sûr que
les alternatives à la viande c'est pas
nécessairement la voix qui doivent
emprunter s'ils veulent être profitable
en parallèle avec ceux l'industrie de
l'alimentation bio c'est eux qui
financent pas aussi secrètement je
réalise le lobby anti ogm aller sur
n'importe quel groupe anti ogm aller
voir trouver leurs sources de
financement
c'est toutes les compagnies et les
grosses compagnies d'aliments bio une
sont opposés à l'utilisation des ogm et
les organismes génétiquement modifiés et
la biotechnologie est au centre du baume
jetables parce que c'est jésus c'est
sale c'est essentiellement de la
technologie alimentaire
les ogm font partie de ceux ci pour la
seule solution mon en sommes
probablement besoin comme l'impossible
burger connaissais pas ce mot malgré ce
bon pour ceux qui connaissent pas
tellement on le paie au canada et aux
états-unis puis pas mal partout dans le
monde dont on fait vraiment pitié ou
canada mais ça repose sur une
technologie qui est ogm parce que il ya
une protéine dans l'intérêt qu'ils
s'appellent l'aiment
en fait que nous ayons réussi à trouver
la même protéine protéine qui est très
similaire à ce qu'on trouve dans la
viande qui donne la couleur rouge qui
donne un peu le goût aussi ils l'ont
retrouvé dans le soya et l'oeil on
essayait de l'isoler du soya et
honnêtement c'était un bordel pas ce que
je veux dire
il fallait qu'il fallait qu'ils ruinent
des quantités massives de soyaux juste
pour alizé lim protéines stupide de
faire ça de façon pragmatique n'a pas
été déjà fait ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
qu'ils ont modifié génétiquement levure
pour produire la fameuse protéine et
puis c'est génial parce que ce moment
ils peuvent produire en masse
l'espèce de protéines rouge et le sens
inné des identités complètes de huy
culture ben oui puis aussi
logistiquement ça n'avait pas de bon
sens n'est pas profitable de faire ça et
lorsque cela leur permettra cela permet
de faire un burger qui rouge qui goûte
la viande et qui peut même c'est nier la
juste eu leur enseignant peace and love
n'avait déjà mangé fait qu' il est très
bon meilleur que bien demi ce moment un
point de vue personnel fait que le lobby
anti ogm sont arrivés tout de suite en
dix ans ok il faut bannir comme
l'impasse buchberger parce que des ogm
de danse comme ok mais c'est quoi votre
argument exactement ils n'ont pas
d'arguments
c'est quoi le négatif de sur écoute et
le premièrement faut comprendre que les
lobbys anti ogm n'ont pas d'arguments un
argument valide à être ralentis auger et
non des vignerons peut on peut soulever
des questionnements par rapport à
certains aspects des ogm par exemple si
l'argument c'est dès les certains ogm
qui vont faire qu'on va utiliser plus de
certains pesticides puisqu'enfin et moi
parlons des pesticides à ce moment là
mais la technologie de modification
génétique a la base je veux dire
scientifique maillot jeté ronis on est
on est certain qu'il ya aucun problème à
modifier génétiquement des aliments non
je comprends mais je lisais justement le
livre de bernard laval et oui sur baie
son premier livre sur changer le
commence à la planète mouche à la fois
puis un chapitre les ogm nous si
justement puis ça traite justement de
tout c'est que certaine résistance aux
pesticides c'est cette résistance à
certains insectes vos phares qui te voir
plus de pesticides compte retrouver un
peu partout observons l'ultime sa part
réuni les écosystèmes noté mais ce sont
des enjeux reliés aux pesticides c'est
pas des enjeux reliés aux ogm
s'il ya certains ogm qui nous qui nous
amène à utiliser plus de pesticides à
smolensk il faut réfléchir c'est
l'utilisation des pesticides en manque
d'air un bon exemple
vous avez entendu parler du glyphosate
impulse est un pesticide qui s'appelle
j'en avais souci le round up c'est le
pesticide le plus solide en amérique du
nord et profiter des milliers voire des
millions de tonnes c'est ça y est
beaucoup utilisé parce que plusieurs des
ogm qui sont sur le marché comme les
mails par exemple qui sert à ils ont
modifié pour résister au glyphosate rend
tout ça un herbicide v ce que sa fille
s'est repris dans un champ c'est tout
sauf le meilleur ce qu'un fake de point
de vue agriculture pour un agriculteur
est extraordinaire parce qu'il ya plus
besoin de faire du désherbage puis tout
ça je veux dire c'est beaucoup plus
c'est beaucoup plus pratique mais la
pression on a commencé à nous d'utiliser
des tonnes de star by side up ya en ce
moment une partie seulement des oies
on a peut-être un peu abusé donc qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire à ce moment il faut
bannir les ogm qu'on a créé pour mais
non c'est stupide ce qui suppose une
technologie fantastique ce qu'il faut
faire c'est que faucons qui a des
agronomes donc les spécialistes de
l'utilisation des pesticides dans
l'écriture qui sont en demande 20 4
comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
différent mais ce qu'on peut en utiliser
moins du glyphosate est ce qu'on peut
nous et peut-être pas dans certains cas
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser ce combiné
avec d'autres pesticides en plus petites
quantités pour nuire - l'environnement
si c'est ça qu'il faut se demander quel
est le lien entre ogm ce qui fait c'est
qui aime beaucoup faire des amalgames
qui est beaucoup dire oh vous aimez pas
les pesticides
il faut bannir les ogm un rapport à part
le l'enjeu des pesticides l'enjeu des
ogm
deux choses différentes ces deux choses
qui sont interreliés mais par contre la
technologie ogm en soi n'est pas un
problème technique
pisi probablement une technologie qui va
être très utile dans le futur vingt six
heures fait qu est ce qu on veut
vraiment se priver d'un outil aussi
utile que ça je dis pas que crée des
menaces barberger c'est fantastique le
choisir la limite du jugement foule mais
la technologie ogm nous permet de faire
des affaires à ces fantastiques avons
été investi de faire des choses plus de
ce que tu disais d'être à place
d'utiliser le stylet le des quantité
incommensurable de soya pour extraire
une protéine si on est capable de le
faire directement t elle même temps mais
tant que pour avoir ta boule est toute
l'agriculture que ça prend pour ta boule
est relatif et jeunes au lieu de juste
en prendre une partie temps prend juste
pour du brasero d'être ce pour créer la
même boulette c'est la même affaire que
pour les animaux si je faisais un des
gros argument environnement
environnementale pour par rapport à
l'élevage tout ça c'est que faire un
titre et un animal qu'on va manger c'est
extrêmement peu productif parce qu'il
faut que tu le nourris ce tellement plus
de fois qu'ils votent de données pour
éviter son rendement l'animal il faut
que je fasse pousser un paquet d'un
paquet de végétaux que tu voles nourrir
plus va te donner un petit quelque chose
je pense à ça de façon purement
pragmatique tu dis c'est n'importe quoi
ça n'a pas de bon sens et josé rossi
port ça suppose soutenable à long terme
cette affaire là mais là c'est le même
argument mais on utilise en des
plongeons insiste effectivement je
trouve juste ça plate qu'un moment donné
ces gens là soient dans une petite
entendu parler de la différence entre la
science puis la croyance
ces gens là sont dans une
voyant ce qui est tellement ancré
profondément qu'ils sont pas ouverts à
des arguments rationnels
tu pourras jamais leur dire ok je
comprends des objections face aux ogm
mais est-ce qu'on peut reconnaître que
dans certaines situations c'est
probablement une excellente voie ils
vont jamais changé d'idée ils ont dans
une idéologie qui est qui est
irréfutable de leur point de vue il est
clairement de mes conceptions encore au
niveau du public par rapport aux ogm le
type premièrement juste le fait que ça
soit étiqueté quinquis ngono gmc comme
vu comme un espèce de plus la confiance
de plus value puis il ya quelque chose
qui sonne mutations que radio actifs là
dedans le tpiy on a l'impression que qui
vont des impacts notre santé qu'il faut
avoir un troisième qui veut nous pousser
les choses comme ça mais c'est moi
j'écoutais ton épisode des aventures de
pharmaciens sur les ogm effect explique
c'est quoi le processus puis c'est quoi
finalement un ogm séquano jamais ton que
faudrait l'expliquer mais pour les gens
qui ne savent pas que il ya plusieurs
façons de répondre à cette question là
mais je vais jamais scié par une voix un
peu un peu bizarre peut-être mais tous
les fruits tous les légumes qu'on mange
aujourd'hui le qui y ressemble
absolument en rien à ce que ses fruits
et légumes la valeur à l'origine quand
manger une belle grosse fraise rouge le
toujours existé les phrases d'autres
mais pas sous cette formule je voudrais
avant le la fraise était pas eu de
grosses comme mon petit doigt péter
peut-être blanche sait mais qu'est ce
que on a fait avec l'agriculture pendant
ce temps des dizaines de milliers
d'années c'est que les agriculteurs ont
sélectionné des souches des variétés de
une phrase que de plus en plus belles de
plus en plus appétissante de plus en
plus sucré et c'est ce qu'on a fait avec
tout ce qu'on mange en ce moment les
animaux si effectivement on sélectionne
artificiellement certaines lignes et
qu'on juge plus intéressant que tu déjà
vu un port destiné à la culture destiné
à sceller les porcs du québec sont comme
ceux qui sont encore des enfants
or mais jallet on refuse de refuge safe
ok puis la bosse et deux ports qui sont
tombés du camion équipé qui sont sauvées
qui ont été recueillis par quelqu'un
gaby dans un coin puis fait classer des
ports sont destinés à être mangés mais
qui ont atteint pleine maturité mènent
ils sont couchés de main basse leur
patron
au petit pour soulever tellement qu'ils
sont gros puis leurs organes sont
tellement petit
parce que ce qu'ils veulent c'est le
plus de viande possible que leurs
organes certainement petits qui peuvent
pas bouger parce que leur corps n'est
pas assez fort pour envoyer du sang
partout
c'est la table s'il c'est gros comme la
table 1 les deux ports sont gros comme
la table sont couchés même son regard de
bouger parce qu'ils ont été modifiées
aux périodes et choisissez les
sélectionne on sait que si on fait ça
cette sélection l'a fait pour l'âme pour
le meilleur pour le pays relance en tant
pis je vais faire juste une digression
parce que j'aime tellement mon exemple
mais les vaches c'est une vache laitière
là moi je te laissera des fermes
laitières une couple de fois le la vache
est plus haute que toi là je veux dire à
une vache sa mesure quoi 6 6 7 7 pieds
de haut en un phénomène aussi
impressionnant puis j'ai entendu à la
radio le jour promis je vais pas dire
qu'il le dit l'homme est une personne
qui est considéré comme une personne
intellectuellement très forte
normalement mais à le dit et j'ai le
meilleur argument contre le véganisme
pour vous quelle est leur 10e succès
mettant les animaux là mais le l'heure
vous avez pas vous vous rendez pas
compte que si on arrête de produire du
lait de la viande du seul et on va il va
y avoir l'extinction des vaches
laitières puis l'extinction des ports
des choses comme ça en six thèmes
blagounette que c'était stupide comme
raisonnement je m'excuse pour la
personne ne l'incité ni les orties je ne
l'entends quotidien et tout le temps
crim ok je pensais que c'était je suis
un an je l'entends quotidienne ok puis
non seulement l'extinction de ces sert à
cela mais la perte complète de job de
tous les gens qui gagnent leur vie avec
avec l'agriculture bah c'est pas faux il
va y avoir des pertes de jobs ou en tout
cas il va d'abord évidemment changé aux
exactions ils vont devoir changer la
nature de leur travail mais ça c'est une
autre question mais mais mais une vache
laitière comme de quoi la leur le polar
de la vache sauvage qu'elle est à
l'origine du fait qu'en cas de dans le
cas d d d d d aliments sains finalement
les fruits et légumes c'est la même
chose mais moi j'ai posé ces questions
là à jean philippe seguin qui est venu
si tous ces animaux là d'élevage si on
arrête le tout les élevages j'en aurais
pu me dis ouais mais c'est un animal qui
souffrent si simone née il peut souffrir
pitre
c'est comme frais tue un enfant pour le
promoteur serait de ta ville était par
exemple telle démagogie comme on enferme
été dans le sens qui est oui oui c'est
dommage pour la razon guillemets sauf
que vous souhaitiez ses rôles dans cette
ville est de toute façon tout ça ça
revient à la question m'emmener delà de
la production de masse le statut que si
on élève des dizaines de millions
d'animaux
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir des dizaines
de millions de ces animaux là pis s'ils
ont diminué la production serait pas
dans une forme d'extinction je sais même
pas pour moi c'est un type d'arguments
on appelle un homme de paille
c'est à dire que c'est pas un vrai
argument notice ce genre d'argument que
les gens soient pour donner l'impression
qu'ils ont bien réfléchi en question
mais j'ose autres ça se ressent à peu
près en trois secondes avec le lien le
lien avec les ogm proche participer à
l'abandon le plus pur esprit cette
affaire le sait que quand on sélectionne
des lignes et lorsqu'on fait en réalité
c'est qu'on modifie génétiquement les
plantes ou les animaux peu importe c'est
que on retrouve à manipuler leur adn
pour obtenir des traits qu'on considère
pas souhaitable on peut faire la même
chose en laboratoire maintenant avec la
biotechnologie et ses superbes vues dans
un laboratoire du fait des modifications
au niveau des bases de l'adn le au tgcc
terreau du fait des modifications
tu vas chercher un jeune dans une espèce
qui est intéressant tu l'insère dans une
autre espèce ou des fois un jeune à
l'inter d'une même espèce tu le change
l'usure le faire en laboratoire ou le
faire en faisant des deux des
croisements ou peu importe jeudi
l'ultime ans a produit le même résultat
le les gens vont dire non parce que
blablabla
au kino mais je comprends sauf que je
faisais à la limite
à la limite ce vin plus c'est un plus
safe de le faire en laboratoire parce
qu'en laboratoire tout ce qu'est ce que
tu fais c'est qu'est ce que touche
control au moins sont ben oui de
saint-pie en agriculture bio par exemple
si ce n'est un bel exemple de
l'hypocrisie de ce milieu là c'est
qu'ils vont dire à une houle les
modifications génétiques le on a ici on
veut rien savoir et surtout leur aurait
donc voulu vous accepter aucune
modification génétique sont comme ben en
fait on accepte de bombarder des
aliments avec la radioactivité pour leur
faire avoir des mutations spontanées
ceux-ci fine c'est une naturelle soit
ben oui mais qu'est ce que naturelle là
dedans ou je sais pas peut-être qu'on
pourrait se faire bombarder par des
rayons radioactifs 2 journal
le superman je ne sais pas c'est bizarre
ou par exemple ils acceptent de prendre
des produits chimiques qui vont créer
des mutations spontanées dans une plante
et l'oeil accepte sur comme étant
naturelle pourquoi parce que c'est du
hasard donc en rien le disque mpo eux
c'est pas la modification génétique mais
il ya un pas qu'on vienne interférer
avec le hasard et le hasard c'est quoi
c'est la nature la nature c'est beau
mère nature
c'est l'idée que l'homme s'interpose
dans un processus qui selon eux naturel
mais on a toujours fait sur quelque
chose de nouveau
le terme naturel sur un terme qui est
quand même flou aussi le très stylé
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient peur si ou la
liberté à tous qui existent je sais pas
ce qui existe à palette très récent
c'est naturel ça existe le cefac si
c'est dur a dit pas en même temps dont
le côté des enfants naturels que je
mangerai pas le meilleur exemple c'est
les pesticides c'est par exemple les
gens vont dire j'aime pas les pesticides
de ça m'écoeure puis tout seul
j'aimerais mieux
j'aime mieux manger du bio ou le juli
juste des affaires naturel
ouais mais c'est des pesticides pareil
et plaisir oui mais son naturel donc
sont sécuritaires
non non je dis ceux des pesticides
naturels ça peut nuire à la santé puis
ça peut nuire à l'environnement est
réduit il y en a plein qui sont utilisés
à la culture bio qui sont nuisibles pour
l'environnement et la santé
la seule différence entre les deux c'est
qu'un actions synthétiques et en os qui
sont naturels
on retrouve dans la nature mais après ça
une fois que te dis surtout pas dit
grand chose
les lilas vrai qu'ils sont tous avancées
sont tus dangereux pour moi ou pour
l'environnement si ça les vraies
questions qui nous qui nous intéresse
1 puis si tu poses des questions là bas
tu vas finir avec certains pesticides
naturels de certains pesticides
synthétiques ça va être un mélange des
deux j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
espèce de markham qui se fait entre la
surproduction puis les ogm
puis j'ai l'impression que la plupart
des gens identifient les deux
automatiquement un veau avec l'autre
alors que les ogm sont les utilisent si
on les utilise intelligemment pas à des
fins de production massive qui vont là
réellement être nocifs pour la planète
c'est positif
ouais ouais la pole je vois pas dans
l'erreur mais le plus gros défaut si on
veut des ogm c'est que les premiers gros
ogm qui sont sortis comme le maïs par
exemple
c'était l'image ce qu'étaient les ogm
c'était ce qui était résistant a dit à
des herbicides comme le glyphosate
non c'est sûr que si on veut dans un
sens on est parti avec le pire exemple
et on a les premiers qu'on a vu
apparaître c'était des ogm qui nous
oblige elles tuent les ai plein
pesticides et là ça nous amener un
paquet d'autres problèmes que des
chroniques sommes partis avec avec
justement le pire exemple mais je vous
donne un autre exemple il ya un ogm que
c'est ce qu'on appelle le rideau résume
john smoltz donc est une sorte de riz
qui émaillent été modifiés génétiquement
pour produire plus de vitamines au
hockey ici honnêtement on aucune intérêt
pour ce le problème c'est que dans les
pays dans beaucoup de pays en voie de
développement les carences en vitamine c
majeures et les enfants deviennent
aveugles à cause de ce nom et beaucoup
d'enfants meurent aussi à cause de la
carence en vitamine e donc le principe
du riz doré c'est le rive comme
fortifiée en vitamines sommes
naturellement tu le fais pour se payer
plus de vitamine a est le but de tout ça
ça serait pour la production de masse
mais la production de masse dans des
pays où finalement des les enfants
deviennent aveugles ou les enfants
le riz doré ça fait écoute ça doit faire
15 20 ans qui prête en bon français là
pourquoi à cause d italie à cause des
lobbys anti ogm
et c'est quoi leur argument ayant non
pas parce que c'est que l'argument tu
peux avoir compte empêcher que des
enfants deviennent aveugles
quels arguments rationnels tu peux avoir
quand tu lis là dessus le lion des
arguments farfelus qui disent ouais mais
la vitamine a est pas bien absorbé s'ils
écoutent ils sont rendus à un niveau le
psy est un bel exemple d'une idéologie
où ils sont pas capables dans le temps
des arguments rationnels avec des ogm
comme ça il y en a plein qui sont en
développement
mais le frein c'est le lobby anti ogm
c'est un lebron james le lobby qui est
anti technologie à la base et ils sont
un énorme frein à un pick-up problèmes
qu'on a dans le monde en ce moment c'est
qu'ici les billets puis utiles à leur
force puis leur financement c'est comme
je disais tantôt c'est aller sur des
sites de groupes anti ogm
regardez leurs sources de financement
c'est les grandes compagnies d'aliments
bio
donc c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
essentiellement pu ou su sont financés
probablement par des des milliardaires
l'eau qui ont de l'argent piché à gauche
puis à droite puis des crises comme ceux
qui financent aussi le bien anti-vaccins
si honnêtement c'est pas un sport c'est
possible si belle toute forme de
financement de grosses compagnies c'est
jamais sans heurts
pharmaceutique ou aux pesticides
n'importe quoi mais ceux ci c'est du
pareil au même le cd growth company qui
finance des lobbys biologique pourquoi
pour driver leur business ultimement
c'est sûr parce que ces compagnies leurs
compétiteurs si les multinationales qui
utilisent à fond les ogm qui disent
exactement ces fous pareils de penser
qu' il ya vraiment des quel point à quel
point le profit puis la finalité la
viabilité d'une compagnie peut nous
ralentit carrément les avancées de la
société en général lénine puis ça c'est
pas peu fière a commencé moins nettement
plus jolie surexcités les gens ils sont
méfiants par rapport aux grosses
entreprises aux gens les grandes
entreprises aujourd'hui je les gens ont
100% raison d'aimer toutes les grandes
entreprises font de la magouille pour
driver leur business type il ya quelque
chose d' extrêmement frustrant là dedans
mais je pense que la meilleure chose
qu'on peut faire c'est juste deux essais
juste d'en être conscient que d'essayer
de faire des choix en fonction de nos
valeurs et puis d'ailleurs j'ai un petit
mea culpa à faire vous permettez parce
que j'étais venue à première fois ici
j'ai une idée parce que j'ai répondu à
beaucoup de monde sur facebook est pas
sur facebook et youtube sur youtube
bien des choses comme en france le monde
sait quand je disais par exemple c'est
l'impact environnemental de nos choix
personnel et grave et quitter oui mais
olivier parce que s'il ya plein de monde
qui font sa maman données l'industrie va
s'ajuster
moi je trouve plus que moi je n'ai
personne un peu pessimiste à la bastille
pour moi être pessimiste six points
c'est pas un défaut en fait même quand
même des études là dessus que les
pessimistes en général s'en sortent
beaucoup mieux dans tous les indicateurs
sont plus en avant juste à être surpris
à la positive ben oui en fait c'est
quand est pessimiste prépare
pour moi c'est juste d'être réaliste
mais bref moi je m'attends pas à
atteindre l'humanité fake
quand je parlais des affaires domaine je
me dis or mais finalement le boom
végétales pour déranger le contraire
c'est à prouver le contraire
le monde trip sur ces beaufs l'aï la
mange il dit c'est bon et le qu'est ce
que toutes les grosses entreprises font
ils se lancent la diff leur la pièce et
leurs bêtes voit présentement t morton
qui of le biome mythe tu vois combien de
compagnies off impossible beyond it en
europe y ont plein d'alternative qu'on
avait pas ici effecté fait le gîte
obligé de faire ou à la force du nombre
c'est le poids qu'on peut avoir comme
consommateur avec des fois la grosse
business qui drive la patente peut-être
que c'est à nous de la manipuler dans le
français ça c'est quelque chose au final
puisque j'ai l'impression que ce que tu
voulais déjà dans fois c'était qu'au
final la décision revient pas à
l'individu utile on aime tant que ie pas
des temps que paul w qui décide de faire
rentrer la boulette bien au mythe
partout au canada
ça se passera pas sauf que pour que
d'autres prennent la décision de la faf
qu'un enjeu moniteurs qui probablement
dû rêver par par une barre ni tout à
fait pire mais en même temps il n'y a
pas de juste encore là il n'y a pas
juste des effets positifs face à moi je
les leaders dans l'info je suis venu je
suis encore plus d'accord avec ça
j'encourage personnes à manger du 19e
puis pour la santé c'est pas la bonne
chose à faire
1 mais quand tu veux manger du junk food
dans un mcdo ou dans un tim hortons dans
un rail w ben honnêtement si tout ces
joueurs se remplacent leurs boulettes
par autre chose que de la viande
considérant que tout ces gens là
mcdonald's sobeys terrasser les plus
gros acheteurs deviennent simples n est
que si ces gens ne change tout pour des
affaires plant based on sent donc tu
peux pas manger de quoi de santé le
dimanche de quoi pour te bourrer la face
puis un jeu avec l'impact que cela peut
avoir son rapport à l'impact possible
sur la santé mais ça peut avoir un
impact environnemental ça peut avoir un
impact sur l'industrie de l'élevage en
général c'est qu'on n'a pas le choix un
peu des des textiles ya quelque chose de
très positif
une malgré que ces peuples e santé puis
que je pense pas qu'on devrais en manger
régulièrement annoncé sur piste est
encore aussi un produit de luxe
c'est une piastre du boulet peut pas
nourrir
une famille avec ce titre de la joint
les deux bouts le texte encore
problématique à ce niveau là mais
j'imagine qu'ils aient plus la demande
augmente et plus compétents vont être
les roses puis les prix vont descendre
nous faxer c'est juste positif mais pour
l'instant ces communautés si le hcc
comme c'est bon pour l'environnement
mais aussi pour le diable s'est pas
arrêté c'est quand il est ressorti le
bio mythe dans les frigos remplis c'est
quoi ça fait à peu près un mois après
donc oui je pense que c'était cette
année 4,6 nous et maintenant ma blonde
et moi maintenant on ce constat belge et
à rien puis en fait ce n'est pas une
grosse différence avec avant la raison
pourquoi je dis ça c'est qu'on sait sur
le site du genre et on consomme invité
un barbecue mougins et nous on
s'amuserait du tofu mariner être cool
avec city ou des affaires domaine qui
quand le fait qu'on n'en parle plus
autour de nous vainqueurs logiques
angers ont sorti leurs boulettes
guillaume mittre pleinement autonomes
nous ont écrit en privé vous avez même
genre et vous devez tellement content
qu'ils sortent les viandes mise en
épicerie mois engrangera pas bleu vous
faites l'association entre les deux
exactement gens nous en europe nous on
est full préoccupés par la santé puis
tout j'en ai fait du bien de chez nous
juste par curiosité xavier bouteille
jetée comme fresnes mais je disais c'est
bon c'est bon sauf qu'ils étaient
pourtant portefeuille d'hypothèques
santé de fauteuils une galette de
pauvreté de file norme nc cent fois
mieux lisser sur moi c'est vraiment une
question claire exemple ce qui est
compliqué c'est plus compliqué c'est
vrai mais c'est le bihan mais cible est
là mais je trouve ça quand même positif
au sens fort goût oui c'est que huit
pièces pour deux boulettes sauf que si
mettons tout en invitant barbecue tube
s'attendent pas de commencer à menez
déboule être temps de commencer à faire
marine est honteux fut tard est obligée
of the si on le sait ça reste toujours
bien huit pièces bon ca coute pas 100
piasses pour de boulettes de ces faits
que je trouve que ce serait intéressant
pour ce type pour comme surtout avec le
temps des barbecues c'est comme ça
facilite la patente
moi j'ai pas de problème avec ce défi
j'ai vraiment aucun problème avec ça
j'ai un problème plus qu'un
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des gens qui
se posent peut-être pauline
nécessairement toutes les questions qui
devraient se poser loti qui est un bon
exemple de tracer le sillon de debian
mythe qui dérobe je pense c'est son nom
je me trompe pas la semaine passée où il
a su leur donner un genre de prix le à
huy ont rêvé de faire donner un prix
c'est comme pour un honneur aux états
unis pour comme protéger la planète ou
protection de la planète catch comme ces
couches probablement qu'il mérite ce qui
- vous se trouvait un couple de l'heure
quand je les écoute parler comme il y
est intéressant pour lui c'est tout son
focus eu tout le temps et istres
l'environnement et le tube where la
semaine passée où il ya deux semaines
il commençait à chicaner avec je sais
pas qui on line et leurs sons points à
lui c'était sûr que notre boule est un
meilleur pour la santé que de la viande
rouge parce que la viande rouge à cause
le cancer et le gosse sa cote de
crédibilité à mes yeux il dans les
pensées de haut à -11 plus dur à
défendre
c'est très dur à d'erreurs aussi
honnêtement puis je trouve pas qu'il
devrait faire cet argument si c'est
exact
exactement déroulé leur ce besoin de
faire ce puits b mais je voyais comme
dernièrement puis en plus ceux qui n'ont
pas fait leur campagne autour du sud
bien mais si on peut parler de santé du
sandwich et puis je voyais je pense que
mario dumont
atv qui au genre fait une comparaison
entre la boulette de viande mais geof sa
boulette de boeuf qui disait c'est pas
meilleure pour la santé mais j'avais
juste envie de faire mais n'y a personne
qui est ce genre est chattent sud
prendre les saucisses à hot-dog que tu
manges piffard l'âme le même exercice
avec ses 6 pour coup de sang qui tuent
sans qu'on attaque c'est quoi c'est quoi
le problème
dans la dernière année la qualité de
l'argumentation à tous les niveaux le
par rapport aux albums aux alternatifs
de viande je les trouvais j'ai trouvé
que ça volait très bas
on a vu des chroniques d'opinion le dans
les journaux le qui disait on mange de
la viande depuis toujours le bon vieux
mathieu bock côté qui se met à parler de
véganisme son article fanatique ça
s'appelle le titre contre la révolution
vegan puis ça commence puis 10 bien que
la question les routes animal est
importante pour y réfléchir je comptais
sur les gammes pour telle raison psicom
à cause que les vegans sont trop
intenses plus qu'un aspect religieux la
patente c'est son argument métier c'est
pas un argument pour compte le monde
intense dans n'importe quoi contre le
monde vont casser des vitrines pour
quelles raisons mais le topo répondu à
aucune question s'y éthiquement 7,6 en
commentant l'entrée ton article c'est
bien qu'ils aient la question de
l'éthique animale soit importante
je suis levé 40 s'est apprécié et très
vite combler fait juste critiquer
certains militants des gangs qui est pas
d'accord avec leurs manières d'exprimer
les la conviction qu'il ya quelque chose
dans ce sujet l'heure qui vient toucher
une corde sensible à tout ce qui touche
à l'alimentation de toute façon c'est
super et motifs fleuris sur elle
c'est culturel exactement meilleur quoi
par rapport à sur moi j'ai vraiment
senti dans dernières années je parlais
de polarisation tantôt le sait des
réactions qui sont complètement démesuré
de la part de personnes qui sont
autrement très rationnelle des gens des
gens que je connais que dans une
conversation sur certains problèmes par
rapport à l'environnement ou l'élevage
qui vont poster une tient un gif animés
de bacon en train de cuire 6 à leurs
arguments le sait une photo de bécanes
enfin tu es aussi leurs arguments dans
une conversation sérieuse une sur des
problématiques reliées à la consommation
de viande jeu comme qu'est ce que tu
penses que tu accomplis en finance à
amor mettre un paquet demandant
crissement ces choses à accomplir
suivant la même chose de dingue j'estime
vraiment je veux dire c'est qu'il estime
aujourd'hui insiste c'est comme
l'éditeur en chef du vogue us et ouais
récemment de passer un coup de jeunesse
et puis tant qu'à chaque fois qu'une
proposition cette affaire je fais comme
moi qui ai réfléchi je la dent il mesure
il est intelligent et drôle plus fait
juste posté une photo de son méchoui
genre une carcasse genres musicaux
quand les vegans wen a forcé que sa
jante atteint les vegan qui répond bien
c'est pourquoi ce qui fait se tait pour
coursan besoin de faire ce jeu contre
sochaux le comprend potes ils ont le
droit de manger de la viande qui en
mange c'est que c'est cool mais de
d'arrivée sow est d'amener ce commun en
fait ce qu'ils veulent c'est de la
provocation
- et je comprends pas pourquoi c'est
nécessaire en même temps il ya des
exagérations du côté des vegan je pense
que quand des extrêmes d'un bar dans un
autre extrême ce que je trouve plastique
je le vois chez des gens qui ont
toujours un mais qui ont toujours du
monde avec qui tu es capable de parler
de plein du sujet donné date puis tout
d'un coup sur ce sujet là en particulier
wall e tu parles chez au total playoffs
si on est juste dans les espèces de 2
d'hyperboles puis de de provocation à
monsieur le catch proprement qui lui
s'est sentie provoqué un certain moment
donné où je sais pas trop d'où ça vient
mais je sais pas c'est dommage j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya un espèce de pub
pis moi je suis le parfait exemple de
sur la vente de commencer à m'intéresser
aux véganisme j'avais un peu cette
attitude là parce que je faisais pas le
lien je faisais pas le lien ce que je
mangeais puis l'animal que je voyais
tiges et jamais je n'aurais jamais
maintenant on fait un montage de d'un
cochon qui joue puis de mon méchoui
après le thé c'est comme la déconnexion
qui se faisait dans ma tête
puis une fois que cette connexion le
suffit c'est là que ça c'est là que ça a
bien créé sur le genre à utiliser
l'outil de poster un méchoui marquant
faut que les vegans longueuil pétroliers
en dessous puis un cochon qui ville ont
ils fait pas le lien et aucun lien entre
le méchoui piste est juste une
déconnexion complète le c'est sûr parce
que c'est une connexion tout un
psychopathe
je suppose t top 6 kopecks mais jusqu'à
belge a donné un exemple s'il ya des
gens c'est les gens qui chasse par
exemple heureux je jure d'être un animal
dans un abattoir de la durance tissu est
moindre comme baptiste un animal la
blague tout ce petit jeu contigent je
comprends leurs points de vue y viennent
outre les agriculteurs moi j'ai parlé d
un sculpteur qui sont super cools
honnêtement puis les aiment leurs
animaux ils les adorent ils ordonnent
d'existence
j'avais été la question c'est se fixer
c'est vraiment comme si je comprends que
des gens qui parlent de ailleurs puis en
même temps moi je peux pas juger ces
personnes là parce que j'ai eu je me
suis instit rationalisation pendant
toute ma vie c'est ma blonde exemple le
titre en totu dit de changer de point de
vue ma blonde quand on était jeune elle
a lu le déclic je prends ça comme si
cette amende n'est qu'à la vue à l'heure
sur quelque chose dans son assiette par
la demande à ses parents si vous appelez
ça du port mais ces petits pois l'animal
que la danse est maussade et riscle je
n'ai jamais eu jusqu'au règlement je le
comprends que c'est pas tout le monde
qui a éclairé les huées après devenu
berger parce qu'au départ c'était pour
des raisons surtout environnementale
direct puis tranquillement puis c'est
vraiment sens c'est sans m'informer plus
qu'il faut c'est sûr j'ai écouté quand
georges laraque est venu écouter en
ligne ses pieds j'ai mieux joué sur fait
subir cet exercice mais les gens
m'écoutent et humain m dans ton émission
de télé d'écouté j'écoutais pas j'aurais
dû garder que de complot contre yvan
marc of n'ont fait que je considère pas
que j'ai écouté j'ai fait j'ai fait
semblant de l'écouté mais en réalité
c'est que je pense qu'après quinze
minutes j'étais trop mal ben tu as
compris l'essence du fai m'a pris 15
minutes puis aujourd'hui le je vois je
t'aime à les camions remplis de cochon
ça avant ça me décrit ce samedi crise
j'aurais jamais passé puiser ses amis
famille venue c'est ça s'est imposée à
moi c'est pas comme conscience et comme
juste émotionnel c'est comme je vois
maintenant pis je suis le pas en ce
moment le on parlait de l'industrie de
la viande vente au leuy entendre des
arguments comme ça puis c'est sûr que
c'est la pire affaire qui peuvent
entendre maintenant je pense que ça les
a même pas compte en dix ans mais bien
en fait non plus d'ailleurs
eux ils travaillent très fort parce que
j'y crois honnêtement qui travaille très
fort pour essayer de avoir des pratiques
qui sont de plus en plus on assiste
aussi à des producteurs qui vont dire
nous leur on veut faire de la relève
de l'élevage d'une manière qui est plus
durable et lille vont mettre toutes
sortes de moyens en place et tout ça
pour essayer d'avoir des externalités
environnementales qui sont moins
négatives pour essayer de traiter les
animaux un petit peu différemment et
c'est son passé le tipi m'adresse aux
gens qui sont en vga un pupitre faut
pour lutter contre ce genre devraient se
réjouir de tout ça c'est des
améliorations le hockey mesure
l'industrie de la viande il avait dû
parlons est ce qu'il ya des ajustements
le fait que n'importe quelles
améliorations que faire je pense qu'on
devrait bien contente jamais de
changement des coupes drastiques dans
rien non plus je serai jouir d'une
amélioration exactement c'est clair
c'est ça reste ça reste un changement
qui me rend très optimiste
ça reste et c'est vraiment la
conversation est vraiment plus ouverte
que déjà été les mêmes mots justes en
deux ans j'ai vu un changement drastique
de discours de tous portent coup droit
il est il autre georges talent et on
avait bâti leur puis on était une gamme
de gants est arrêtée au et w puis la
moitié des blogueurs qui ont mangé ces
débits en mai ce qui est quand même mode
puis j'étais le seul vg vegan ouais
ouais puis d'ailleurs c'est un produit
qui est fait pour interpeller les
mangeurs de viande pour ceux qui font
que ça goûte on espère à terme en
éduquant ça fait plus tout jeune c'est
comme ça et puis je savais même pas que
tu étais rigide et maintenant mais mais
c'est quand ça fait un bout de temps
maintenant que tu manges tu deviens un
bonus comme doit plus besoin que ça
goûte la viande au chargement de l'avion
c'est ce que je me lance jacques bolzan
en fou maintenant état fût marine et je
me suis autant à ces maladies de fille
marine et de ce barbecue j'ai fait aux
défilés aux arachides fou oui fakty m
mais c'est ce qui s'est produit le lion
ils ont leur place sur le sur le marché
fait que puis comme tu dis à un boom
montbard qu'on le sait la paix le groupe
pessimiste on parlait encore une fois il
ya un boom en vente à ce boom les
mesurer combien de temps c'est parce que
tu as un effet de mode là dedans
faut pas se le cacher il ya un effet de
mode ou du monde qui embarquent dans le
monde
puis qui vont débarquer éventuellement
l'homme vous avez bien deviné qui ont
fait leur ipod sion ils sont devenus une
compagnie d'un public très
en bourse puis tout ça leurs actions
alors comme skyrock été comme le débile
et là depuis une couple de jours le ils
sont en train du scion le sont en train
de tomber puis vont probablement cracher
une bonne partie très inquiet je sais
pas peut-être il fallait s'y attendre le
jeudi à sion hype incroyable autour de
ces produits là puis amony va y avoir un
rétablissement qui va faire que ça va de
revenir à quelque chose de plus normal
un bon exemple de ce que j'ai c'est
beaucoup de beaucoup d'influenceurs des
influences euse aux états unis entre
autres des vedettes des célébrités des
youtuber qui étaient des célébrités
vegan et ben je sais pas si vous en avez
vu le mais que tout d'un coup d'oeil
annonce ait squash témoins des vidéos
youtube vient de plusieurs mois dans la
dernière année on a vu beaucoup le du
monde le ddd décidé d'aider des
comédiens et comédiennes extérieur
qu'ils disent écoute je n'étais plus
capable de gamme ce n'était plus jugé
plus capable de soutenir ça et le jour
où j'ai recommencé à manger de la viande
je re devenu à la ville il ya même une
actrice qui disait que ça a c'est sentir
huit bouteilles locale a commencé à
manger de la viande
et ça ça et lesbiens l'effet de mode
ouais c'est à dire que ces personnes là
dessus il passe d'une mode à l'autre
mais qui vont faire la diète c'est aux
jeunes ils vont faire le jeu un
intermittent ils vont faire le sans
gluten ou et simon faire le véganisme
mais il passe d'un extrême à l'autre
fait qu'ils y ont pas l'espèce deux
périodes de d'ajustement de réflexion
ouais ou tu réfléchis à ok mais logent
va le faire progresser je veux changer
quelque chose toutes choses sur le jeu
manque de protéines ops le jeu manque de
tal afar web finalement mon supplément
bains douches mais le drame ils passent
pas par ça et surtout le pourquoi je
veux le faire
destination la plus importante et parce
que c'était pas un bon pourquoi il faut
revenir
exactement mais à cause de psion crash
parce que ils doivent être dans une
diatribe sont dans une diète extrême
il passa non dits et extrême à laquelle
n'ont pas réfléchi ayant des effets
négatifs relié à seuil souffrions décret
ring ouais moi je pense pas que c'est la
bonne façon de faire cette transition le
jeu tamar en sachant exactement pourquoi
tu en est convaincu dur de revenir
l'autre chance c'est de revenir quand
que tout ce qui est question d'éthique
anima tu y crois vraiment que tu le
ressens vraiment qu'ils étaient informés
sur les questions environnementales
c'est dur de revenir après ce cas tu le
fais parce que ça
barkat différentes tailles respectives
la mode passée sur c'est ce qui va avoir
ce mes mais en même temps c'est pitié en
réalité la bonne chose moi j'étais venu
végétarien du jour au lendemain
oui dans le pays puis moi je sais
comment je fonctionne personnellement
s'il faut que je commettais quelque
chose puisque si je meurs de viande
tendre et à cette exception ici et là
que j'en ai mangé gentil père manipuler
j'étais moi je sais que c'est comme ça
que je fonctionne comme ça que je
fonctionne dans toute histoire de ma vie
mais en réalité pour le commun des
mortels l'important c'est de diminuer
l'importance et au lycée de
tranquillement
faty c'est sûr que si tu fais une espèce
de gros changement qui passe de grands
mangeurs de viande des gannes jour au
lendemain puis que tu penses que ça va
être facile petit pense qu'il est petit
fait ce juste pour les paraître en plus
cette offre aux jeunes et aux projets
miniers pas une bonne façon de le faire
dit il ya des gens que je connais autour
de - 6 qui ont coupé deux jours
lendemain pillon rester comme soient
puissants coups lui tirer mais est-ce
que c'est comme ça que la plupart déjà
ça va fonctionner probablement pas parce
que la majorité des changements
importants qu'on fait dans une vis mon
pot jour lendemain qui si on regarde en
europe en ce moment le plus gros segment
le cpo des végétariens ou des vega et
cetera cdd des risques appel et les
réductionniste logis un nom pour cela
mais c'est le jacky flexitariens vrai
comme moi je cherchais procès consulté
quelques riffs lourds mais c'est
essentiellement des gens qui mangent de
moins en moins bien c'est le plus gros
segment en ce moment il ya beaucoup de
compagnies entre autre en anglais
l'angleterre en ce moment c'est un
espèce de berceaux un peu injuste ce
mouvement l'olympie la bosse lyon ayant
remarqué sa grossesse et du monde qui
coupent la viande fait qu'ils disent
arrêtez pas on va vous offrir des
alternatives ça va se faire
progressivement les gens mangent de
moins en moins découvre des alternatives
qui leur plaisent comme puis mon
expérience personnelle moi ça a été
comme plus progressivement puis pour moi
ç'a fonctionné depuis comme man et
j'essayais du lithium barista dans mon
café que j'ai fait comme cette affaire
là c est bon pour l'instant j'aime plus
que l'effet que j'osais je pense qu'il
ya vraiment pas une bonne façon de le
fermer
mon avis dépasser drastiquement sans y
avoir réfléchi non mais moi c'est ça moi
ça a justement ce à méditer le plus long
c'est ça ouais mon fils et je voyais les
fêtes arrivent et le pôle opérateurs
puis précieux de 2 janvier 2011 19 ans
s'est récemment j'étais sur un tournage
dans une petit village le genre
saint-calixte de nicéphore du l'accord
et le boucher betty etc
[Applaudissements]
la base de l'accord est en fait si je
les ai inventées cette partie là mais on
était sur un tournage parce qu'on est
allé sur un champ pour voir de
l'épandage de pesticides voir comment ça
se passe
puis ensuite on a pilot fallait vos
mensonges fait que l'on arrête dans un
espèce de porc laqué qui ont pensé que
c'est un bar de danseuses fait qu'on a
fait et feront pas au palais où le
phénomène est quelqu'un qui rentre en
métal et on est allé manger loops et là
je regarde le menu outils puis le menu
c'est comme c'est un menu de petits
balais petit village qui je veux dire on
est et le jeu voilà il y avait plein
durables de juin rap qui semble être
végétarien que je commande se rappeler
le rat qui m'arrive avec une grosse lab
de boeuf haché de grosses lable qu'un
comme deux deux boulettes de steak haché
pendant ce temps plusieurs madame g
excusé je pensais que j'avais commandé à
l'abri de rien me regarder comme mieux
rien de végétariens sur le menu ici et
là tout est il est trop tard pour
changer de menu le parce que ça a pris
du temps à savoir ça on est pressé il
faut qu'on s'en aille
moi j'ai foi king failli si j'enlève la
boulette de boeuf dans mon affaire
il reste la salle est une espèce de
sauce loge que je veux pas savoir ce que
c'est c'est fake je les mange et les
maudites boulettes de boeuf lopy gpoms
je pense pas eu envie de me fouetter
avec un fouet après jugement en gamme
moi même
moi personnellement j'en ai pas de
réelle de ces comme garde
je mange pas de viande 95 et plus pour
cent du temps puis - citant les actions
à un moment donné ou si je pense qu'il
faut être capable de respecter ce que ce
que chacun reprend de tes actions
système gaspillé ou man l'industrie fait
qu'en double c'est comme s'ils mettent
en danger en se retirant du loup c'est
comme si tagattitude et vegan jeunes en
même temps garder rabier pleine déroute
des cubes et tous les autres qui jettent
pâté croûte de cuir zippées content d'y
émettre et ou petit peu les données
n'étaient pas capables des voix mais ces
âmes en essais
il est mort le lui l'était at il à la
bon ça nous touche que j'avais pris un
cube hall de bon si on était allé au
resto j'avais pris un sandwich pistait
tranches de pain blanc avec l'aide du
sud au nord
puis georges vinaigre balsamique
voiliers de bon ben c'était le nom et on
fait ironique ce que tu dis oui je pense
[Rires]
qu'on a vu on avait une espèce de
longues journées puis tout ce que
j'avais mangé cette journée c'est pas
super mais j'ai une question pour toi
parce que je sais pas si j'espère que je
me trompe bouge pas c'est mike white qui
disent ce qu'ils disaient moi si je vois
dans une place puisque rien de vega n'en
mange et je mangeais juste des frites
maintenant c'est où j'ai déjà rencontré
quelqu'un disait - des fois y'a rien
mais allez manger qui est une passion
qui est également inscrit que dix mois
j'ai déjà mangé juste du pain pendant
toute leur peau moi je ferai jamais ce
serait jamais ça parce que c'est même ma
mission si on veut être le pharmacien si
de promouvoir des bonnes habitudes de
vie la santé que c'était un fake
moi jamais je leur conseille à quelqu'un
de manger juste des frites pour un bon
repas ou jamais joué conseillé de manger
juste du panier mois pour moi c'est plus
un moment donné suffit ce qui est
possible dans la mesure du raisonnable
c'est moi c'est plus comme ça que je le
vois tu
moi je vois c'est un point de vue là
dessus moi j'ai pas et c'est peut-être
la seule fois cette journée-là à cuba
c'est peut-être la seule fois où est ce
que j'ai vu un problème
maintenant dans mon niveau d'énergie ou
damas pas ma santé globale ne tombe de
mon alimentation puis s'était pas parce
que c'est juste parce qu'ils avaient
aucun choix temps généralement qui avait
aucune si j'avais eu des frites
j'aurais mangé des frites puis je
réponds eu cette belle énergie le
drastique la fin de la journée tout ça
dérangeait pas de manger un report de
scrabble un repas mettons des justes de
frites
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres options
je vais arriver chez nous le soir je le
mange unsa de légumineuses avec des
légumes puis en huitième je veux
retrouver ma balance d'un jeu complet à
ma journée le tir je comprends ça m'est
jamais arrivé de mettre dans une
situation est pire qu'il le faut je
mange que des frites pendant quatre
jours de suite le tir ça m'est jamais
arrivé c'est fait que je comprends je
vois pas pourquoi met-on chant pop j'ai
absolument besoin à chaque repas d'avoir
tout ce qu'il me faut à 100%
non mais je pense que personne qui vit
de cette façon là à se dire dans mon
assiette trois fois par jour je veux
tout les nutriments parfaitement de
cactus et assiettes parfaitement les
personnes qui fait son effet je me dis
une journée mettons que un dîner juste
un an un resto il ya rien j'aime prendre
des frais de pipe une salade janvier
puis le soir je mangerai des protéines
chez nous jean pas que j'ai besoin de
absolument chaque repas d'aller tang et
surtout ce que parce que mon corps a
besoin
non mais je suis d'accord c'est
maintenant tenir le bâton pour une
journée je suis d'accord là dessus a
limité ses possibles mais je donne un
autre exemple c'est maintenant moi je me
déplace souvent joie pour des salons du
livre pendant une semaine à l'extérieur
ou des confins du prophète dit tournée
j'ai fait une tournée au lac-saint-jean
exemple brice a menti et puis il ya des
endroits où c'est pas mal plus difficile
de manger végétarien couacs au saguenay
j'ai été surpris j'étais capable avons
pas mal d'options mais des endroits
défaut ou un moment donné le sincèrement
malgré tous mes meilleurs efforts si je
veux pas manger de viande ce que je vais
manger s'est dit pas totalement se
mettre des paroles observer des portes à
tous du rapport - le jeu manqua pas de
manger dit pendant six jours j'ai pas
capable je faisais ça marche pas fait
que c'est comme si avant mais je me dis
dis pas qu'elle est ma façon de voir les
choses c'est la bonne mais même j'ai
juste dire que moi dans le fond quand
les gens même endroit mais où la limite
exactement comme pour moi la limite est
juste arrivé à publier les noms mais
c'est ce mot moi je pense pas que j'aime
me rendre à dire ok sera pas là je mange
du pain
je peux pas imaginer un tueur aux joies
brand là mais je pense juge pas les gens
qui le forme nécessaire mais mais mais
tige c'est le moment de la fête la façon
que je vois si c'est surtout québec le
moineau moncton une épicerie où est ce
que tu es ou à proximité au wake up call
of realtors
juste une épicerie tu peux avoir
n'importe quoi fais que me dit à port 1
400 avortement une baisse des places qui
sont moins modernes qu'au québec et
j'imagine ben may toronto pas d'épicerie
yahoo
une demi heure pour manger moi ça
m'arrive je pense que tu es toi tu es
quelqu'un qui aborde la vie avec la lune
est rationnel avant tout le titre je
pense pis t'as manière d'approcher
l'alimentation puis le truc est purement
rationnel c'est tandis qu'eca kick ass
période quelqu'un qui prend la posture
de morale je sais pas trop de moi je ne
mange pas ce parce que un c'est un
commitment que je prends avec moi même
puis deux
ça me fait pas sentir bien et je me sens
trop mal le cpie de la rationalité dans
l'émotivité et y mais qui qui qui valide
aussi été parce que oui c'est correct
quand tim mon point là dedans
essentiellement c'est juste que je suis
comme je disais tantôt tu sais moi mais
ce que j'essaie de faire c'est vraiment
encourager les gens à avoir un esprit
critique mon apport à leur choix en
matière de santé qui de faire la
promotion des bons choix de santé des
bonnes habitudes de vie et c'est
érotique novak c'est sûr que je vois pas
diriger les gens vers des aliments entre
autres en ce moment je veux pas
encourager les gens à juste à manger un
paquet de pâtes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres options
tu sais moi j'aime mieux qu'un personnel
grande variété puis cac coupe une partie
de sa consommation biens d'une personne
qui me dit seul qui dit elle c'est quoi
j'ai dû ne la viande je mange plus de
végétaux c'est épique indiqué ce que je
peux faire de plus même je sais pas
honnêtement ce que tu fais c'est cool de
georges pourquoi tu veux en faire plus
le reste est libre à toi si tu veux
faire plus que ce fait le mois mais moi
en termes de conseils généraux sont
exacts tendance est d'accord et qu'il
arrête sinon la date à date heure les
émissions qui s'en viennent
ces colis sujet des sujets préférés
santé peut pas vraiment parler
non non je peux dire par contre que dans
l'être voilà je travaille sur la saison
4 en ce moment puis il ya sept ans après
quatre saisons tu t'es tu sais un peu
plus comme mode en ligne et moi ce
qu'est le sujet qui qui marche bien
heureuse de marché même pas par rapport
au public malicieux moi la question que
me pose c'est parce que le public va
mais seule la question c'est juste
capable d'assumer mon propre sujet
puisque je vous parle aussi avec le
pharmacien je traite de sujets qui sont
souvent
perçu comme controversé fixer des sujets
sensibles puis quand j'ai commencé
saison 1
j'avais peur un peu utiles comme vous
c'est une émission de télé grande écoute
c'est fake je pense que je me mettais
beaucoup de barrières rendu saison 4
c'est comme si le total atteint un
certain niveau de confiance puisque le
il ya des sujets qu avant j'aurais
jamais par georges jamais parlé du sujet
le jeu je me sens à l'aise le frère
inquiet en même temps je me trouve des
fois j'ai l'impression que défi des fois
j'ai l'impression que je m'en aille vers
un suicide professionnel il ya trois
sujets cette saison aussi le livre il
était juré je m'étais juré de ne jamais
en parler je m'étais juré le tu vois
avec le temps je me dis ok attend que tu
as un moyen d'en parler un curieux qui
savez je m'excuse de dire ça à plat mais
qu'elle soit près de six chansons je
m'excuse de vous utilisez comme ça c'est
vraiment pas cool de ma part mais là où
je veux en venir aussi avec ça c'est que
il ya une tendance que j'ai remarqué moi
moi j'ai moi j'essaie toujours d'aller
chercher des des experts dans chaque
domaine je serais allé chercher des gens
qui sont souvent pas interpellé par les
médias c'est donc souvent moins la façon
je trouve mes expériences et que je vois
lire des publications scientifiques
j'essaie d'en trouver qui ont été
publiés au québec puis julie les noms
des auteurs jugent cette personne n'est
sûr telle publication fait l'objet d'une
expérience en voyez crie au
bâillonnement des puces presque
totalement on est content saison 4 de
ses loger le plus de misère avoir des
interviews accordées sujet à cause non
même pas honnêtement c'est à cause du
climat actuel et je te dirai que jamais
l'heure jamais j'ai senti autant
d'hésitations chez les scientifiques à
parler publiquement sur le sujet que
même les gros sujets controversés je te
parle oui mais même tout les sujets là
c'est comme si d'un coup le mont et com
- ge ben accord avec toi c'est important
d'en parler je suis content que tu le
fasses mais j'ai pas de me faire crever
les pneus de voiture je me suis fait
dire ça j'ai pas me faire crever les
pneus de voiture que j'ai fait assez
bonne iliad une annonce et panju mon
collègue m'a parlé de ce sujet là c'est
fait crever les pneus de voitures yonne
je vais atteint c'est vrai ça arrive
pour de vrai ça c'est comme si on met
tout est au courant le docteur pascal
pointait déjà reçu des menaces et des
enfants victimes ces quotes-parts
oui mais honnêtement ça me scie les
jambes complètement ce com comment est
ce que rapidement on n'y en aura plus
le passé dans un climat de tension
extrême rapport aux sujets scientifiques
de la réponse que je reçois le plus
souvent ce moment c'est olivier on a
dans ce que tu fais on est d'accord avec
toi m'ont peut pas participer convention
parce que les risques que cela comporte
pour y sont trop importants puisse dire
c'est qu'ils risquent d'être associé
avec moins non on veut pas en parler
dans la presse on veut pas en parler
nulle part on ne veut pas se mêler de ce
sujet là jamais parce qu elle ment
problème on va faire notre job
on va avoir des pressions on va avoir
des menaces c'est tellement problème est
ce que c'est que la raison d'être est ce
que c'est parce que tout le monde
une voix pratiquement égale aujourd'hui
que n'importe qui peut répondre à
n'importe qui donc ici moi qui connais
absolument rien au sujet méconnu du
sillon qui pensent que si qui pensent
que ce qui est convaincu que quelque
chose je peux écrire une réponse à ton
article où est ton émission qui va être
aussi vu il eu que tournée mission en
tant que tel qui se fait qu'il ya eu
aucune hiérarchie dans la qualité
lang menteur oui c'est pas sa part écrit
pierre schultz s'il vous plaît mais mais
mais c'est oui je suis tout à fait
d'accord ce sens ça fait partie de la
problématique globale mais ça explique
pas pourquoi est-ce que présentement
bien pourquoi ce qui est un espèce de
baume et prochain boom végétal ya un
boom de peur aussi par un brasseur une
conspirationnistes ou comment t'appelles
rsa
c'est un baume conspirationnisme il ya
un bon anti science sans conscience très
très très très fort puis je pense que on
peut y penser naïvement et se dire oui
ce parce que tout le monde peut parler
sur les réseaux sociaux puissent et les
réseaux sociaux pour soi puis oui c'est
une partie de la réponse mais l'afld il
ya un élément qui est plus important que
j'ai passé un an à réfléchir à ça parce
que avec tout ce qui m'est pas ce qui
m'est arrivé à paris mais si les you did
you des groupes qui drive son lancement
il ya des groupes bien organisés et bien
financée qui drive le discours anti
science c'est à dire que c'est payant
puis on a parlé un peu de temps en taule
mais mais c'est payant de propager de la
mauvaise information
puis je veux donner un exemple de ce que
je faisais ça va valoir
conspirationnistes ok mais ça ne l'est
pas ok vous aurez lire là dessus la
russie le gouvernement russe fait des
campagnes de propagande anti vaccin anti
ogm sur le web
c'est vrai il a été démontré pourquoi
ils font ça
pourquoi le gouvernement russe se font
ce chiffre est ce parce que c'est dans
leur avantage de créer le chaos aux
états unis
oui ils prennent des technologies
surtout eu en russie sont pas fermes en
biotechnologies non quand ils maîtrisent
pas bien ces technologies peuvent donc
c'est à leur avantage de créer de
générer de la peur en amérique du nord
l'eau ou les biotechnologies on est très
fort là dedans donc c'est à leur
avantage de créer
finalement un des craintes et de
propager de la propagande pour créer du
chaos parce que le chaos
ça nuit à une société que ça nuit à un
pays et pour eux c'est bon c'est ça leur
donne un avantage politique on le vus
dans la campagne présidentielle avec
trump il ya eu une implication en plus
là dedans c'est le même principe c'est
bibi jeu de stratégie de rome c'est ce
principe le aussi de remettre toujours
en doute les autorités ou lis la science
ou six exactement midi les mouvements
sur c'est quelque chose de très très des
matons l'homme a donc été rendu que le
gouvernement russe mais à plus petite
échelle maintenant les groupes anti
science sont très bien organisés ils se
parlent ils savent comment s'y prendre
si maintenant ils savent que pour
réussir pour arriver à leurs fins ils
peuvent pas juste faire du bruit sur les
réseaux sociaux
il faut qu'ils sa cote avec des
politiciens qui réussissent à les
embarquer dans leurs affaires et là ils
vont peut-être réussir à avoir du temps
au parlement pour aller parler de leurs
choses ils vont passer par la voie
politique qui vont passer par du
lobbying etc
donc je pense que les gens sont pas
conscients de tout l'est de toutes les
engrenages qui sont allés en r2 me suis
dit c'est payant mais à quel site qui
parle de paye en payant financièrement
ou d'ipad d'apple mais c'est quand même
des gens qui probablement sont
convaincus d'avoir d'abord la vérité sur
le sujet donné j'en doute pas mauvais en
soi même ce même si on évoque une
évidence c'est je ne peux pas militer du
forez petit cas pas pour militer aussi
fort pour telle ou telle cause pour tel
ou tel ou pour la maladie de lyme
chroniques poursuit pour exemple vous
que tu es convaincu que ça six clés ça
existe moi je pense je pense que oui
effectivement tu sais si je pense pas
que ces personnes le son intention et
désinforme intentionnellement non je
pense que c'est des gens qui sont très
très convaincu mais c'est des gens qui
ont 4 chez comment la machine fonctionne
pas qu'ils disent ok ça suffit propos de
super une page facebook est d'aller
chercher du monde qui s'amassaient
fonctionnera pas donc c'est là qu'ils
vont chercher celles qui vont chercher
des politiciens c'est là qu'ils vont
essayer de s'incruster dans le système
de santé par des portes
des bacs d'orpi etc et le pire c'est que
ça fonctionne toi est ce qu est ce qu
est ce que tu as été surpris de surcôte
est tombé quant à propositions dans
toute histoire de la vitamine c est ce
que comme tu es tombé là tu peux tout
attendais pas du tout à la puissance
derrière derrière derrière quelque chose
qui pour toi semble tellement tellement
claire elle est totalement
moi je suis toujours surpris les sujets
où je m'attends obéir loti ou que je
suis comme le cheick parce que j'ai peur
de voir la réaction se passe rien
c'est un exemple de sujet où cette année
au pays ben oui on a parlé tantôt de
l'épisode que j'ai fait sur
l'accouchement dans la saison 2 par
exemple cet épisode leleu me terrifiait
le vérifier ou l'épisode sur
l'allaitement que j'ai fait pour toi
pour une seule bonne raison ça concerne
des enfants puissent tchèque est très
émotif fait que souvent ça amène des ça
amène souvent des arguments qui font un
homme qui est maintenant une grande cité
du sud
effectivement c'est donc donc juste un
bon exemple si je m'attendais au pire
ces deux épisodes ont été reçus le
magnifiquement puis toupie c'est juste
pas fier de te met maintenant et j'ai
fait un épisode sur les suppléments de
protéines chez les sportifs puis je me
suis est menacé de me faire casser du
c'était surprenant notamment avec la fin
de la vitamine c c'était un de ces
sujets là pour moi c'est un sujet ben
ordinaire ce qui arrive c'est quand même
emmené pour ceux qui sont au courant
il ya une pétition qui commence à
circuler beau faire supposément approuvé
les injections de vitamines c
pour les personnes qui ont le cancer
c'est pas pour traiter le cancer
s'exposer main que ça diminue les effets
secondaires pour les gens qui sont sur
la chimio est quelqu'un que de la
chimiothérapie pour leur cancer ils
disent que s'ils sont injectées de la
vitamine c est au moins d'effets
secondaires de la chimie aura moins de
monde qu'un ou des choses comme c'est
bon t'es que la pétition circule la
pétition comme beaucoup beaucoup en
popularité avec moi j'ai fait un article
comme jean phi sur n'importe quel sujet
day est une pétition qui circule
voici ce que la pétition demande j'ai
pris chacune des demandes une après
l'autre
j'ai regardé sud reste à faire le saut
logique ça à toute censure qui avait pas
grand chose qu'ils avaient du sens là
dedans donc j'ai fait ce hameau d'une
façon candide en m'attendais à ce que ça
soit un peu naïvement bah oui si je me
disais je me disais en fait je pensais
que les gens feraient comme à nice coule
je les signer la pétition et maintenant
je suis plus à commander ou je me
demandais s'il fallait je la signe tout
de suite
je m'attendais pas à ce qu'il semblait
appris d'où vient cette idée lequel elle
termine ses études à ce sujet lors qu'il
disait qu'il y avait des des bénéfices d
un truc sans vitamine c est ce qui déjà
us qui ait quelque chose derrière ce
qu'une science est une super aviez ideye
le je pense que ça remonte aux années 50
avec le sporting chimiste qui a gagné
deux prix nobel pour deux affaires un
prix nobel de la paix parce qu'il y
avait des trucs qu'on pense les nazis
vous juste pas trop quoi lâche pas trop
ce niveau là qui a aussi fait un
il ya aussi gagné le prix de la paix un
prix nobel en chimie pour une découverte
de haut niveau des liaisons chimiques
un scientifique incroyable qu'il est à
la fin de sa carrière il ya panier
déchets irles devriez commencer à penser
que la vitamine c ça me fait tout guérir
tout au tout qui existent le cancer la
belote tout ce qui encore aujourd'hui
les gens continuent à croire que lui ce
qu'ils pensaient à l'époque ça a été
prouvé ou démontrer tout en réalité à
toutes les fois que ça a été testé ces
hypothèses ça marcherait jamais et là
dans les dernières années il ya eu un
regain d'intérêt un peu pour 7,6 des
loques la vitamine c peut faire plein de
choses mais la réalité c'est que des
études qui disent que ça guérit x y z
jeunes à la chose que c'est guéri c'est
le scorbut carence en vitamine c et
promet de prendre les injections de
guérir il est vrai bien sûr ça c'est
assez facile à aller chercher
de nos jours on est assez facile à aller
chercher mais dans le cas du cancer
c'est particulier parce que tu l'aies
jacquet est revenu on est revenus des
câbles d'aller chercher des
concentrations beaucoup mais vraiment
plus élevé que ce que tu pourrais aller
chercher avec des comprimés par la
bouche
donc c'est là que commence à dire ok
mais tu vas chercher des concentrations
aussi élevé ce que ça peut pas avoir un
effet justement au niveau sanguin au
niveau justement des des effets
secondaires des de toutes les mécanismes
qui se passe avec la chimiothérapie le
sait sur la cse leurs prétentions
mais quand tu arrives avec ok voici
mais voici où on en est scientifiquement
voici les résultats de dzfoot le sujet y
a pas vraiment création en des
injections de temenos et puis
des bénéfices et des propos il ya pas de
preuve pas de preuve que ça marche il ya
même certaines preuves que ça peut ne
pas marcher et probablement être
dangereux donc quand tu arrives avec ce
comment c'est reçu que c'est quoi la
réaction parce que clairement la verte
la réaction cessé de nier ou 6 2 et dans
d accord avec toi mais c'est quoi la
comment ça se manifeste si colas si j'ai
eu vraiment un bon mélange
la plupart des gens qui ont réagit mon
antique était super contente comme
marcoule c'est intéressant je l'avais vu
cette pétition le chapeau tôt pour
penser les gens qui supportait la
pétition guillou qui était très très
investi là-dedans parce qu'il l'avait
signé
qui croyait vraiment la patente c'est
sûr qu'il y en a beaucoup qui était pas
content du tout ça mais là ce qui s'est
passé c'est que moins ce sujet là je
sais pas pourquoi mais ce sujet il m'a
interpellé plus que d'autres c'est comme
si j'ai fait je sais pas il ya quelque
chose d'un sujet que je me suis dit que
quelque chose là j'ai senti que juste
antique cinq ans que c'est un conte un
peu charnière
j'ai vu comment ça s'enligne pilote d'un
coup j'ai vu au pilote d'un coup il ya
un politicien et les lire il laisse
pillay est en train de dire que lille va
prendre cette pétition le qui veulent
amener à l'assemblée nationale
voilà défense va faire des pressions le
j'entendais des affaires entre les
branches qui avaient des profils la
santé qui avec s'était senti obligé
peut-être de donner de la vitamine c
les huit syndicats qui avaient plus que
je suis la question le voilà qui avait
quelque chose qui sous-entendait qui
était sous jacente ou soir j'ai senti ce
n'est pas juste une compétition en ce
qu'il y avait vraiment un mouvement dans
d'autres ce qu'ils voulaient vraiment
faire quelque chose puisque j'ai
l'impression que ça paraissait un peu
sous le radar puisque le tout d'un coup
tout s'est accéléré peut demander même
le politicien en question il ya même dit
m on veut savoir commission
parlementaire avec s'appuie tout seul ce
qu'on en attend plus on va vraiment
investir des fonds publics là dedans
pour une commission parlementaire pour
parler de quelque chose
ultime mais que ce devrait être juste
une question de qu'est ce qu'on sait au
niveau des données scientifiques sadr
est juste sur la question qu'on se pose
adresse terminé le bas c'est à dire que
un médecin le
si vous paraît son premier temps vous le
savez comment ça marche un médecin a
prescrit un ca prescrit un médicament
s'ils jugent que le médicament est
efficace qui est sécuritaire si au poste
épreuves là mais problème est qu'il vaut
pas le prescrire tiens parce que c'est
juste nous a beaucoup apprécié aussi
poétique dans le vent est en train fait
que pourquoi est ce qu'on demande
d'autoriser des injections prendre à
d'autres réseaux ne pas autoriser reims
pour illégal
si les médecins prescrivent pas c'est
parce que on n'a pas de preuves qu'un
médecin il va pas faire quelque chose
pourquoi pourquoi passer par un
politicien qui est pas un expert en la
matière qui s'y connaît peut être pour
que lui mettre la pression sur des
médecins ou c'est leur domaine de savoir
si ça n'a aucun sens pour moi c est
coutume est vraiment le doigt sur la
patente
moi j'ai senti qu'ils avaient de
l'ingérence il y avait de l'ingérence
politique dans un sujet qui est purement
scientifique c'est là que ça m'agaçait
avec g si j'ai fait beaucoup des mises à
jour sur cet article pendant un an à peu
près puis plus en plus à aller pire
c'est à dire qu'il y avait un groupe de
personnes qui étaient probablement des
signataires la pétition j'imagine mais
que progressivement le jeu voyait des
messages passaient ils sur les réseaux
sociaux que le j'étais devenu comme
l'ennemi à abattre
c'est comme un banc de neige était sur
mon facebook le jeu voyait saviez vous
que le format schiste pour un vrai
pharmaciens en personne qui vient de
découvrir ce jeu je trouverais pharmacie
commencé à avoir des défauts aux
informations qui circulaient sur -1
manie avec jean reuilles une autre fake
news du pharmacien tél affalé m'accusait
du feq news ou le chagrin matin c'est
comme trame fait aux états unis nakic
accuse les immédiate fightnews sicile
après ça il y avait quoi y avait aussi
au wii avait aussi des gens qui partent
et des citations il disait voici ce que
le pharmacien dit aujourd'hui bla bla
comme j'ai jamais dis ceci comme tu veux
je peux vous ceux qui ont pris cette
citation aulas à une situation
complètement inventés ou oust et deux
bouts de phrases qui avait pris dans
deux commentaires les avais millionnaire
de los teques panade et moi ayons comme
c'est comme si on monte un faux
personnage qu'ils se sont comme monter
un personnage que je suis pas c'est dans
le sens aussi dans ce que je fais des
fois je te veux acheter un peu baveux et
puis tout cela mais pendant ce que si je
trouve pas que je l'avais été vraiment
je trouve j'avais été quand même propres
mais ils ont vraiment créé le personnage
qui est un monstre essentiellement et là
c'est sûr qu'en faisant ça ils ont monté
leur trou et on craint que leur champion
du gard leurs machines
pas un vrai pharmaciens garder les
enfants qui a dit qu'ils n'ont pas de
bon sens il fait défection aux fsi fait
ça et le tout d'un coup il ya un paquet
de man qui ont fait ok stogran le cas si
le jeu est tellement longue et qui ont
créé la wii mais oui c'est ça c'est le
personnage images qui ont dressé un
[ __ ]
pis selon toi le catillon est ce que tu
penses que c'est un groupe organisé
fonctionnaires ou 6 10 c'est une gang de
loup solitaire mais qui agit de la même
façon en même temps je pense que c'est
pas un groupe organisé mais je pense que
c'est des gens qui se sont parlés sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui ont décidé un
moment donné de façon informelle de
comme faire une sorte d'action c'est en
disant par exemple mené puis le sait ce
qui est arrivé c'est ça a été des mois
et des mois vraiment là que c'était un
niveau de haine et d insultes qui
étaient quotidiens le vraiment le cas
j'ai jamais vécue que tu recevais un
message privé un message public les
devoirs tous les deux pipi honnêtement
ça ne dérange pas jean ça me dérange
vraiment pas que tout est quelqu'un qui
est quand même une bonne carapace à ce
niveau au dessus honnêtement mais pas
taxées jeudi seul fait que tu fasses
aimé ce que tu fais - il y en a pas
beaucoup qui ferait ce que tu fais à la
bande iii mais je comprends ce que tu
veux dire
en fait je pense que la façon je le vois
plutôt si il ya un travail qui doit être
fait puis moi c'est comme si je les
accepte et je les assume que j'essaie de
voir la façon c'est moi qui décide faire
le pharmacien c'est moi qui décide et
parler du sujet qui sont sensibles au
fait comment n'ai je peux pas me
plaindre après que ça crée de la que ça
crée de la simili contrat vert josé
ramos comme j'ai un quart était de faire
ça si ça me plaît pas je l'accepté
lehoux a mené cinq hommes fauqué si on
veut c'est que m'emmener moi je sentais
que c'est en train vraiment d'accès les
risques patente là à un niveau vraiment
camion jeunes et là le fameux pot
lithium en est en fait un pot sur sa
page facebook où il dit ok on serment en
commission parlementaire avec ça c'est
la troisième pétition la plus populaire
de tous les temps et la commission
parlementaire vont nous permettre d'en
savoir plus finalement sur les
injections de vitamines c et le moi j'ai
fait tout bonnement j'ai fait je voyais
écrits restent goal of et j'y ai cru sur
son pont puisque la main je lui fais
toussaint un commentaire sont pas au
110e
monsieur x le politicien j'ai dit
je lis vos affaires le pouvez vous nous
expliquer juste questions simples
peuvent expliquer en quoi une commission
parlementaire vont nous en apprendre
plus sur le sujet grâce essentiellement
à des questions scientifiques seules à
ce stade ci fait que pourriez-vous juste
nous éclairer sur la question en gros
c'est ce que j'ai dit et là c'est pas
possible
l'avalanche et le la cellule qu'ils ont
fait aux cristaux doit le on le tue le
saignement et et lorsqu'on fait
essentiellement c'est qu'ils se sont
comme consolidé pour dire que qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour le cas ces dons
qui ont fait des appels à tous en disant
ok tout le monde on porte plainte
massivement radio qu'un parce que radio
qu'en dise mon diffuseur
ouais et le radio can d'un coup obs ils
ont écrit à un écrêtement radio kahn à
qui d'autre on peut écrire à il ya le
fond telus qui finance sa série télé à
toronto on va leur écrire massivement au
fond telus pour qu'ils quittent des
finances sa série à qui donc on peut
écrire on va dire alors des pharmaciens
portons plainte massivement à l'ordre
des pharmaciens à ok après ça aion blanc
nuit sa blonde senza desjardins à
l'écrit dit romain on boycotte ces
livres ont fait un appel au boycott de
ces livres si on dit que les livres de
ma blonde des torchons et qu'il fallait
les boycotter
ma blonde a eu aucun rapport avec ce que
je suis qu'un petit ils ont révélé
l'adresse d'une pharmacie où je
travaille l'ama faire la ferme la
pharmacie principale je travaille et il
y aussi des menaces de mort au traverso
mais limite ses efforts des pays
européens et leur nettement moi j'ai
fait ok sorry mais là c'est plus quelque
chose que je suis prêt à accepter un jeu
maintenant prendre des insultes pendant
huit mois là mais je dois pas accepter
ce pour moi le ce a franchi une limite
que ça devient dangereux quand même en
boîte
ça atteint un niveau où on peut pas et
on off il ne faut pas qu'on accepte ça
c'est là que j'ai fait mon j'ai fait un
statut sur ma page pour en parler puis
le rebelle c'est un fait mais dieu merci
tu es passé at il dit quand même parce
qu'il ya eu un espèce de changement de
paradigme - exactement en fait ce qui
est arrivé là c'est que moi je parle a
dit moi je disais et si ça serait le fun
qui a aidé associations médicales
scientifiques qui qui viennent ans qui
parle qui prennent position sur le sujet
qu'ils ont collègues qui parlent tout ça
parce que moi je prends une experts de
tout événement les gens peuvent toujours
the wall pharmaciens connais pas ce que
c'est mais les gens qui sont dans les
portions d'autoroute scientifique il
devrait peut-être en parlent et qu'ils
prennent
laissez moi c'est ce que je demandais
mais je pense que c'est un sujet qui
était perçu comme sensibles personne
voulait vraiment se mouiller qu'un
convoi qu'est ce qui t'arrive à toi et
ne va pas avoir beaucoup de monde qui
voulait se prêter au jeu
c'est à l'oeil le savais pas ça répond
que non ils savaient pas encore s'ils
savaient pas ce que je vivais ça se
faisait un peu en dessous lice en
coulisses et le quand j'ai fait ma
sortie en espèces qui se passait le je
pense que c'est surtout quand tu parles
du changement de paradigme c'est clair
il ya un pas que montrent qu'ils ont
fait
ok ça se passe au québec c'est à ferland
ce moment on le savait qu aux états-unis
en arrive des enfants comme ça le club
du harcèlement qu'on fait perdre les
jobs à des scientifiques sur des enfants
pas de bon sans pilote mais il ya un
paquet de jeunes en communauté
scientifique à temps mais ça n'a pas de
bon sens je faisais ça on peut pas
laisser faire ça et l'autre d'un coup
y'a pas que nous étions sortis en disant
ok mais le goal on va on va se prononcer
publiquement fait à la limite le plus
grand succès de cette affaire là ça a
été ça a été que tu ne me sortir des
gens des six a amené un peu de warner
city ça fait que des gens qui étaient
peut-être un bon j'étais pas au courant
que tout ça se tramait lost au courant
hockey le il faut qu'on se prononce et
loeb alors ça fait ça fait beaucoup
switch unies s'est prononcé ce qui est
désordre est ce qu'il ya des colères de
médecins ou quoi que ce soit qui se sont
prononcés entre la faveur de la position
maintenant oui et plusieurs joueurs
professionnels
mon or d'entre eux qui m'ont beaucoup
supporté la taz leur très très
reconnaissant entre autres l'association
des hémato oncologue plusieurs colloques
ou s'ils écoutent des groupes
d'étudiants dans science à l'université
des étudiants en médecine plein plein
plein plein honnêtement le site et comme
j'étais pas dans un bon état
c'est comme si ça me faisait chaud au
coeur mais en même temps je te dire une
étude de semis panique dans le sens où
j'essayais de 2 m drôle parce que j'ai
eu jean nohain j'ai eu un enfant il a
fallu qu il fallut que j'ai un apple
maniac radio can pour leur expliquer ce
qui se passait qui ont été super cool en
pensant être vraiment avec moi y ont
fait au levier on le sait c'est que dans
mon lit si ce que tu fais on le sait
dans quelle situation je peux te
retrouver
on va te supporter jamais eu de doute à
leur niveau non mais mais sa momie dans
un stress quand même incroyable qu'on
sait ma blonde aussi à trouver cette
offre c'est un fake fait que j'étais pas
capable de l'apprécier à sa juste valeur
mais il ya vraiment plein plein de gens
qui ont de la communauté scientifique
qui ont pris position et qui ont dit
cheikh l'analyse que le vieux fait c'est
une bonne analyse
on a les mêmes conclusions il n'y a pas
raison d'avoir une démarche politique on
y avait sur ce n'est pas ce niveau
approprié inscrits est-ce que depuis
tout ça est ce que tu as remarqué un
changement dans le paysage un paysage
scientifique de la façon que les gens
prennent la parole ou où ça a été juste
une vague puis si lors disparu aussi
lequel c'est arrivé c'est dur à dire
tiens je pense je pense pas qu'à ce
stade si on peut dire s'il veut vraiment
un changement à ce niveau là je pense
que je pense que le score était vraiment
bien c'est que vraiment comme jay carney
c'est à dire que maintenant les gens
sont conscients que c'est vraiment
difficile le parisien et que sa mère et
que mine de rien ça peut mettre beaucoup
de pression sur des fois des personnes
individuelles des répercussions
positives que ça hue et peut-être que
ses répercussions alors peut-être que ça
va faire en sorte que ça va changer le
paysage comme tu dis c'est que il ya eu
deux choses en particulier problèmes en
leu
il ya mis un bureau gouvernemental et
scientifique en chef du québec
c'était en fait c'est une personne
s'appelle rémi quirion c'est un
quelconque une carrière incroyable qui
était un chercheur je pense les manèges
poste oui qui est commune sur deux
consultats pour le gouvernement sur des
questions scientifiques et le lui a mis
en place une sorte de comité finalement
de réflexion une sorte de comité
consultatif pour réfléchir à cet
incident la et comment est-ce qu'on peut
éviter que ça se reproduise plus comment
est-ce qu'on peut aussi de créer un
climat un peu plus de confiance entre
les scientifiques les médias et ses
terres pour finalement qu' on soit
capable d'en parler des questions
difficiles
donc ça mon avis ça va avoir des
répercussions positives
je sais aussi que les autres
professionnels plusieurs ordres
professionnels cinq six se sont mis
ensemble qu'ils ont créé un groupe pour
la même affaire en se disant les
prochaines la santé souvent il se
prononce pas publiquement parce qu'il
paraît que c'est un impact sur leur job
et on parle que ça ait des répercussions
déontologique ti donc dont ils ont créé
un groupe pour se réfléchir à ça aussi
je connais ce qu'on peut les appuyer
comme est-ce qu'on peut épauler les
prochaines la santé pour qu'ils aient
moins peur de se prononcer à 71 pts est
seul problème c'était que le monde était
au courant en réalité mais qui voulaient
pas se prononcer parce qu'il avait peur
des impacts sur rue ou sur leur
association dans un an deux ans trois
ans cinq ans on sera peut-être capable
de dire que les notes que c'est au
moment tu as sorti puis de la vague de
soutien aux us que ce que l'élu en
question est ce que le mouvement est ce
qu'ils se sont retirés ce qui lui s'est
rétracté il ya peu le choix
en fait problème c'est vraiment
distancés quand y'a juste à faire le
lycée tout de suite distancier de la
pétition en 10 ans et enfin j'étais pas
au courant qu'il y avait de la dja
réellement sur quelqu'un à ce niveau les
loges encourage vraiment posture et le
lieu dit en passant ce n'est pas une
démarche politique cette affaire l'eau
si moi je sais juste dans mon rôle de
député des fois d'appuyer certaines
initiatives citoyennes l'oms ait pas un
mot si j'ai de la misère avec ce c'est à
dire que c'est comme une façon puis je
n'y prête pas d'intention le chou ceux
qui avaient les meilleures intentions du
monde le député en question
c'est juste qu'en même temps je pense
qu'il faut leur dire aux députés
si à un moment donné quand les
scientifiques disent là que ça tient pas
la route le complexe est une initiative
citoyenne
mais parce que sur une question
scientifique faut par exemple scientisme
beaucoup d'occasions ce que je sais pas
si c'est un domaine où est ce que c'est
une question d'opinion c'est bojan pour
ou contre l'aéroport de neuville qui
fait du bruit picks and go cela s'est
passé c'est pas une question de question
de faire une question des sciences une
question d' objectivité fax est pas une
affaire d une valeur de jugement obtenu
par des commissions parlementaires pour
des questions justement où il ya matière
à débat public jeune je suis 100% pour
soi mais quand c'est des questions
scientifiques auxquelles on peut
répondre à l'aide des données probantes
de la littérature scientifique bail
qu'on freine comme si on va jaser
d'affaires et en plus si je peux me
permettre dans les commissions
parlementaires les experts qu'on évite
ce n'est pas généralement l'immersion
qu'on voudrait que par la tue le suspens
du monde qui on est et chérie people qui
ont été choisis pour dire ce qu'on veut
et puis moi je trouvais que c'est toute
société théâtrale fait lui aussi un peu
de distance de thua et finalement la
pétition à le planter qui honnêtement je
ne sais pas si tu à cause de tout ce qui
s'est passé quand ils y ont décidé de
paul à retenir parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
vision pas juste dit on peut juste dit
ah ben là on a fait une réunion et on
dit non la pétition ne la retient
d'europe
donc qu'est-ce qui a créé ce est ce que
le fait que toute la communauté tous les
coups c'est soulever ça tu contribues et
dont on le sait pas mais moi je pense
que ça apprendre à jouer un rôle
tu avais publié à mener tout assorti la
conversation et avait eu avec je pense
que stigmatisent ces envoyés quand même
les différents niveaux d'argumentaire ou
de ton assez drastiquement tout était
très objectifs et les plus cordiales et
polis possible puis c'est vraiment pour
attirer sur socle faisant baisser vrai
permanente et issa le dépasser une
limite de 10 le te dépasse les limites
donc je vais arrêter de te répondre
parce que les saf et puissante mais
c'est une conversation qui a duré
longtemps en deçà personnes mais où en
quelques semaines je parlais de la
semaine passée c'est sale affaire c'est
que si les pays riches ne me touches je
fais déjà un peu sarcastique 5-0 puis
moi c'est bon tu sais mon seul souci est
il qu'ils font n'est pas une seule qui
plaît à tout le monde jusqu'aux oreilles
il ya des fois que je pars trop bas
plus mais je pense que des fois les gens
savent pas que d'avis que les gens si
les gens vont lire les réponses aux
commentaires que les gens c'est un jeu
tout en ajoutant un commode impliquant
les jeunes écrivent en privé je répond
presque tout le monde et puis pour notre
temps des bonnes conversations et puis
moi je total ouverts est ce que je
trouve à l'évidence que si c'était la
même chose du genre
si on n'est pas d'accord puis on peut tu
veux parler normalement tout sur moi
c'est tout le temps sur mon attitude
fait mail à partir du moment où on en
est tu te rends compte qu'ils à nos
potes la discussion à l'avance pau où il
n'ya pas de façon vraiment été mieux 12
heures au quai tchèque
on a dit ce qu'on avait à se lancer
voilà c'est tout passe tout est perçu
dans le fond dans leurs yeux étaient
perçus comme commenté perçu comme le
gars l'expert qui arrive puis kiki et
qu' aucune pitié envers les victimes de
cancers qui veut pas qu'il y ait des
meilleurs si ça un peu qu un quinté
point fort mais prend la main
la perception d'un certain public ou de
ce qu'ils vivent
c'est dans le fond ce pour que ça touche
autant les gens puissent ressentir ce
parce que le cancer instigué rien de
plus oui désastreux et rené plus
horrible que c'est plus triste que cet
épi le toit qui vient amener une espèce
de nuances à des gens qui veulent juste
s'en sortir the kid est une solution qui
est aussi tout charmant même taille même
dalle dans l'horreur faut garder notre
activité un peu comme se lancer dans oui
oui pis ce qui drive ces personnes la
peine ne sont pas les personnes qui ont
le cancer passe en quelques mois j'ai
jamais eu de cancer le fait que je peux
pas imaginer c'est quoi d'avoir un
cancer ça doit être vraiment horrible
vraiment vraiment off mais les gens
justement qui qui qui militait pour la
pétition n'étaient pas des gens qui
avaient le conseil général ça peut être
des gens qui ont un proche ou etc mais
ce qui drive ces personnes là dans un
sens c'est ce qui me drive moi aussi
c'est à dire que le camp son joli c'est
à quel point est-ce que c'est sensible
puis je le sais à quel point ce que les
personnes qui ont le cancer sont dans
une position de vulnérabilité des
personnes sont en position de
vulnérabilité ben il faut qu'on les
protège
ils y sont ils sont dix est possible
qu'ils se fassent vendre des infractions
le joli ciel j'en connais des gens qui
ont le cancer
ils seront proposées toutes sortes de
bébelles traitement ésotérique des
enfants ces personnes n'ont en fait il
ya des mêmes des études qui ont démontré
c'est quand même si c'est pas beaucoup
de recherches là dessus mais ce qu'on
sait c'est que
une personne qui a le cancer et qui
auraient recours à des thérapies non
scientifique alternative à l'autre de
deux faux 2 de deux à six fois plus de
chances de mourir de son cancer même pas
de substituer le même pas de dire je
prendrai pas ma chimio puis je dois
prendre du jus du champignon chez agoa
placement mais juste d'ajouter des
traitements alternatifs en plus haut
même si ce fait toutes les mêmes la
forêt mais tu ajoutes des truelles et
deux ensembles routiers donc de
substituer y prenant plus en général
donc probablement que d'avoir recours à
ces choses là ça t'amène dans une
cascade de décisions
ou peut-être que tu tu prendras
peut-être pas toujours les meilleures
décisions et est donc forcément quelque
part ça peut venir ça peut être aussi
des effets secondaires reliés aux
produits la vitamine c est un bon
exemple tout le monde me disait que
j'étais un écrin parce que mon point
c'est que ça n'avait pas d'efficacité
puis en fait qu'il n'y avait pas
d'efficacité de démontrer c'était ça mon
point que il dit que j'étais un fou
parce que il ya des gens qui disent que
ça marche pour eux qui m'ont jetée comme
weah temps c'est parce qu'il ya aussi
des données qui indiquent que ça peut
annuler l'effet blanchissent thérapie
longs filaments cinq ans est sérieux
cette affaire le lendemain les gens
s'accrochent tellement aux exceptions
lionne exotiques fait moi je connais
quelqu'un qui taille dans une retraite
de yoga en inde puis qui est revenue
cinq ans en héros de cette histoire là
se fait transporter au gré du vent d'une
personne qui est arrivé petit nom ça
peut marcher plus quand tu penses qu'il
n'y a plus aucune ressource d'innonce il
ya une histoire que ça a marché fait que
ça va marcher pour moi aussi dit au
final ce c'est fascinant ce que tu viens
dire qu'au final de prendre cette
décision l'a amène sûrement son lot de
décision qui va nourrir atteint guérison
possible mais moi si ce qui me frappe
justement si si si vous gérez penser que
justement la latitude était jeu ma
chimio mail à un tel mot dit que de
prendre de l'huile de la nasa va m'aider
au pis au pire ça peut pas nuire ces
faits que je veux le faire mais ce que
tard ndri sais que ça peut littéralement
nuit tout le temps oui c'est sûr parce
que
le monde s'imagine qui vont prendre des
traitements alternatifs ou naturels ou
mixtes europe et que c'est sans danger
ans aussi probablement une des plus
grandes croyances qui complètement
fausse par rapport à ces traitements là
c'est qu'ils sont sans danger
ça existe pas un traitement qui sont en
danger dit d'ailleurs moi je trouve ça
quand même drôle que des gens puissent
s'imaginer qu'une substance peut avoir
des idées des bienfaits très important
donc ça veut dire que cette substance
heures à des halles une action
pharmacologique nageant sur le corps
humain à leur juste des bienfaits
obligataires mais c'est impossible qui a
créé quelque chose de négatif soit mais
si tu es molécule est aussi puissante
pharmacologiquement allons sans taxes
jusqu'à un médicament ou importe que ce
soit une plante whaou talent eu accès
aux médicaments une action
pharmacologique presse qu'elle n'aurait
pas d'effets secondaires
ces tutus chiale contre les effets
secondaires du médicament meta substance
à toi et sans danger c'est complètement
irréaliste que je pense ça vient d'une
mauvaise compréhension
je sais pas de la physiologie ou tout de
suite mais j'ai un questionnement que je
veux lancer
moi j'ai la ferme croyance que la
science vont éventuellement une capable
d'expliquer tout dans la connaissance
objective wade de façon objective tout
mais que des affaires qui est encore pas
capable d'expliquer
oui mais moi je suis persuadé que les
trucs qui se passent mettant des
histoires etc mettant le ice man 3 1 les
gosses c'est un gars qui est capable de
rui se met dans le marais puis c'est
quoi son nom les comme un nom de viking
c'est jean paul année dans l'au-delà
jean-loïc puis son corps reste chaude ce
plat tout le monde fait comme what the
fuck pluie explique cela par sa
technique de respiration
là il la prend comme sa technique de
respiration m'ont dit c'est vraiment un
énorme bug c'est pourquoi est-ce que ça
s'peut pourquoi personne ne sait
vraiment y fait que le mont attribue
cela à quelque chose qui va au delà de
la science mais ce que je pense c'est
que la science éventuellement vos catch
up sur ce toit et ont déjà compris une
bonne pas expliqué pourquoi est ce que
cette technique de respiration la
fonctionne et aussi des vieux mythe le
team étant dit les histoires tirées des
tribus qui est arrivé c'est un dieu qui
tombait du ciel le bleu 2001 puis
finalement en creusant il trouve des
espèces de piste que peut-être qui est
vraiment un événement historique qui est
arrivé à ce moment là qui fait que tout
est foutu garde une certaine ouverture
par rapport à certaines affaires à plomb
sur plus flyé il qu'on n'est pas encore
capable d'expliquer laitiers ou toi tu
t'en tiens réellement ajuste qui prouve
et maintenant moi faites le la façon
vous répondre à ta question cebaph et
oui dans un sens mais pas prêt à
toulouse il y avait un gars qui dit que
monsieur monsieur fait cette citation me
chercher le succès les intéresse le
celtic fait l'essai est important
d'avoir l'esprit ouvert mais pas au
point où ton cerveau tombant à terre
moi c'est un peu sur mon attitude c'est
à dire que moi mais ma position
épistémologique le ch'ti surprend voir
l'arrêté du jeune rouillé mais c'est
très très abondant penser de parler de
notre position épistémologique le sait
comment est-ce qu'on acquiert des
connaissances dans la vie mais moi ma
position épistémologique si c'est ce
qu'on appelle le scepticisme
scientifique le se sont achevées avec le
pharmacien est ce que ça dit
essentiellement c'est que on se dit mais
une infirmation quelconque c'est
vérifiable
puis on devrait essayer de la vérifier
puis si on n'est pas capable d'avoir des
preuves qui sont suffisants pour faire
cette affirmation le bon devrait éviter
de la faire c'est vous on devrait la
faire avec beaucoup de prudence
en gros c'est ce qui me semble très
raisonnable le tient je dire si tu veux
dire qu' il existe des éléphants roses
avec des cornes
c'est la moindre des choses que tu n
certaine forme de démonstration que ça
existe c'est jo c'est juste ça donc
autrement dit ce que ça veut dire c'est
que tout est possible mais dans la
mesure où on est capable de d'en faire
une certaine preuve jusqu'à un certain
point
ce qui veut pas dire qu'il faut est
ouvert à 100 % des enfants est en jeu et
ce quelqu'un veut marquer que la fab un
farfelu ch comme fine mais le niveau de
preuve que tu vas devoir m'amener voight
il faut d'abord correspondre au niveau
d'extravagance de ton information
d'ailleurs ses gains chouchou des
quotidiens d'aujourd'hui vit pas
quantifié vraiment c'est vraiment par
jour
vu ce que je dis d'amis et carl sagan il
le dit dans le fond c'est que une
information extravagantes exige un
niveau de preuve qui est extravagant si
tu dis quelque chose qui est très très
surprenante genre de parler des affaires
qui sont descendus du ciel ou des
familles soit mais c'est normal que tu
arrives avec des preuves suffisants mais
moi je te faire à n'importe quoi c'est
même à la limite ce moment de ça existe
oui fantôme moi je comme j'aimerais ça
que ça existe les fantômes salaf hawking
cool d'avoir des fantômes n'arrive mois
avec des preuves qui qui qui qui sont
qui sont suffisantes pour pouvoir au
moins laisser un doute là dessus et il
s'adonne que sur tous ces sujets là en
général la réponse tout les alternet
toutes les espèces d'hypothèses que le
monde ont comme puis on va prendre ton
exemple du golfe iceman mais ils ont
étudié legault quai puis proprement et y
aura d'abord une capitalisation très
importante qui est un peu différente le
genre il ya une capitale je pense qu'une
circulation sanguine vraiment plus
importante que les autres crient que les
autres surtout au niveau de la surface
de la peau pas sa température de surface
il y en à faire comme sur le genre sa
température ne change pas comme les
autres personnes quand il est dans l'eau
glaciale les deux gars là ça peut être
une anomalie mais ça veut dire que le
reste de l'humanité peut apprendre à
speech et dans l'autre l'artiste avec sa
respiration fait qu'on peut l'étudier
puis à la fin la réponse aux requêtes
des luis enrique rule teams et après
ceux qui enseignent sa méthode pitt ou
tiff les ans c'est là que mon niveau
fort que ce cas pas de prouver que cette
étude a produit d un dtv les fantômes
c'est un des sujets que choko ferait un
sondage piqué on serait étonné de voir
quel point mettant les gens qui y
croient en des rester là dedans
ceux où met-on les médiums le tcb nos
modes de vie mais c'est toujours nouveau
l'anecdote cf falloir médias me
maudissent au chili a aucun moyen qu'il
s'abîme au 10e et pis c'est incroyable
comme on n'était jamais là ils ont alors
eu aucune aide ouais puis dans le temps
les tirs les scepticisme scientifique
une grosse partie de tous et aussi de
prendre des affirmations des expériences
que certaines personnes ont eu d'essayer
de trouver des hypothèses alternatives
telles que quelqu'un te raconte l'enfant
qui est complètement abracadabrante le
genre j'étais chez nook de koutoukalé
toutes les trois on va les ustensiles
sont mis à voler parce que comme disait
honnêtement je pense
difficulté à croire unique de prophètes
matin une hypothèse s'apprête maintenant
que la personne était peut-être en train
de faire une sorte de rêve éveillé ou
quelque chose comme ça où ça peut être
une hallucination ou six avec sursis de
trouver des hypothèses alternatives
puis une théorie qui est très important
tant dans le domaine l'esprit critique
je pense l'avait déjà entendu c'est un
spa une théorie c'est un principe c'est
le principe du rasoir d'occam un bout du
continent non principe du rasoir d'occam
le j'espère que je veux bien l'expliquer
sinon je me faire blast est aussi quant
aux 2 4 2 une cathode plus plus qu'une
théorie pour expliquer un phénomène qui
semble inexplicable
tu devrais être toujours choisi la
théorie ou l'hypothèse qui demande le
moins qui demande d'assumer le moins de
choses possibles
je vous donne un exemple quelqu'un dit
j'ai vu un objet dans le ciel sûr que
c'est un des extraterrestes un vaisseau
extraterrestre
ok mais que c'est quoi les théories des
risques après que ces désespérés
une autre théorie s'apprête que c'est un
satellite que c'est un phénomène
météorologique que c'est un avion que
ces x y z
laquelle de ces tirs il te demande
d'assumer le moins de choses si tu dis
que c est son intérêt ce le faut que tu
assumes des enfers en calvaire
l'affectation pour les extraterrestres
existent qui a dit que de la vie
ailleurs dans l'univers qui sont une
technologie suffisante pour se promener
qui sont capables de venir sur terre
qu'il ya une raison de venir sur terre
bla bla bla faut que tu assumes un
paquet d'affaires assumer si tu dis que
tu un avion un satellite de rien assumer
c'est quelque chose d'impossible
c'est fait on essaie de faire les
calculs d'évaluer les possibilités de
chacun des trucs l'exacte sur son
associé puis finalement tout va vraiment
le prendre en compte que si tu penses
que c'est à venise pas parce que tu
penses que serge le plus probable c'est
parce que tu veux y croire
non tu as fais vraiment depuis cette
affaire le dis pas que tu as raison tu
as raison c'est justement née dans des
situations tu ne peux pas prendre une
décision tu peux pas savoir que battu
devrait toujours aller dans le sens de
qu'est-ce qui te demande d'assumer le
moins d'affaires abracadabrant suisse
d'affaires leur bain en général de tt
des conservateurs ce qui est pas mal
d'être conservateur sur des affirmations
fauqué ses progrès de prudence une bonne
posture de projets en fait prochainement
dans les derniers temps et comme une
espèce d un groupe facebook pour storm
ah oui au fait aux etats unis c'est
quand même ils disent qu'ils ne peuvent
pas nous empêcher toute la gamme de
rentrer avec lui comme tout le monde
c'est comme redevenu à la mode mais au
fil des mois l'autre jour j'étais je
double take je suis quand je parle ça
faire le jeu par quelqu'un
et puis je dis comme avec tous les
arguments que j'avais reçue par
l'interminable dans les derniers jours
c'est que c'est vrai et c'est pourquoi
est-ce qui est ce qui empêche les gens
de rentrer l'api l'oeil comme un
scientifique qui est qui est sorti un
scientifique qui est sorti de l'eau en
disant qu'ils avaient travaillé sur un
moteur qui est capable de de se
propulser dans toutes les directions
plus + moi j'étais là on a menti
pourquoi il nous empêcherait de rentrer
là s'il y avait rien à cacher de ses
pleurs parce que je parlais plus parce
qu'ils testent des armes puis veulent
pas que ça s'en aille ailleurs plus j'ai
fait
ouais ouais rasoir d'occam c'est
exactement ce pas déçu mais grand jour
le gouvernement fait des tests d'armes
qui veulent pas que le public sache
hockey fait tout les sens le toujours
une explication plus dupes une normale
plus fort john logan et à verser je sais
que tous les poteaux j'aime pas c'est
que je trouve que son choix d'invités
est discutable je pense que c'est là que
tu veux ben on l'a fait les prochaines
éviter je pense que c'est quelqu'un t'a
brest est mentaliste bana tchèque sous
son nom d'artiste que je copiais melty
lui lui dit magicien ce type au médium
outils du mentalist comme un magicien
qui fait des prix cloutier qui lui passe
il ya passé sa vie à bosse td des gens
qui sont vraiment des arnaqueurs qui se
disent mental est stipulé qu'ils
allaient à les exposer puis aussi à
médiatiser médias moi qui ce médium
c'est qu'ils font vraiment un pouvoir
surnaturel paisible dans 100% des cas
ils capables de dire c'est quoi la
stratégie est quoi le truc est employé
phi phi même des gens qui se disaient
médium bien qu'ils ont mis dans des
environnements contrôlés vraiment tu es
avec laboratoire finalement depuis
qu'ils ont observés il n'y avait aucun
signe de pouvoirs surnaturels
historiquement les magiciens ont souvent
été dans une position privilégiée pour
détecter la bullshit des charlatans
parce que c'est des illusionnistes et
déjà y invente les trucs eux mêmes fait
que les connaissent les trucks et je
peux vous connaissez jane brain 10 juin
10 était un magicien est un
prestidigitateur vraiment qui inventait
des tours puis tout ça et il est devenu
un des plus grands 10 banker finalement
de patente de bullshit celui qui avait
dit 'ben qui dans le temps c'est un vin
qu'on ait vous et moi mais j'en
rencontre pliée dès des cuillères à thé
vexé l'uruguay leur des médiums et déjà
que parler aux morts des domaines
il y en a plein d'autres qui font ça
parce que c'est clair c'est eux y pour
eux c'est juste comme je faisais le même
taux dans mon show c'est juste que toi
tu fais encore aux gens que c'est de lui
aussi ressaisi
enfin c'est la même affaire a mené
j'avais entendu c'était un duo qui qui
faisaient des taux est ce qu'un avion
qui se dirigeait dans full pleut ils
regardent ils prenaient le portefeuille
de quelqu'un ou exemple le il sortait
une carte pelé disait je fais juste
pensé oh non puis il faut que la
personne devant lui trouve le nom puis
avait expliqué qu'il faisait le c'est un
exercice de mémoire phénoménale c'est
encore plus impressionnant que d'être
capable de lire des pensées pour moi
piste est selon selon les mots qu'ils
utilisaient pour dire je viens de
prendre votre portefeuille puis je viens
de regarder votre nom sauve vote sur
votre permis de conduire mais tendent
tous des parents des mots qui s'usaient
y appelait le nom enfin que jarry avait
il y avait une panoplie de phrases
possible pour épeler le nom de la
personne dans les phrases l'utilisait
pour parler à son à son amie en haut il
y avait comme une panoplie de
possibilités
il est plein non666 c'est de la pure
magie là c'est vraiment un travail de
magicien parce que c'est comme comment
est ce que je peux en passer une petite
vite aux gens que c'est tellement
brillant mais que je vaux comme réussir
à les avoir tués d'accord avec toi sur
ceux plus impressionné vannes au mans il
y en a aussi qui ont été plus touchés
comme des évangélistes américains qui
faisait des miracles supposément
puisqu'il était capable de calais genre
ou et gerald
in qui souffre d'un cancer de la vessie
en réalité il y avait juste comme il y
avait comme un chose comme ceci en une
musique qui ont utilisé des techniques
beaucoup plus strict
il ya tout le temps un taux à dix ans on
sera encore là c'est une business cette
affaire même si je suis je suis vraiment
la difficulté puis parce que il ya comme
une résurgence des médiums des liseuses
bonaventure et si vraiment la stratégie
ultra à la mode ces temps-ci sandrine et
a moi ça me dérange profondément les
amis dérange profondément parce que moi
j'y crois pas du tout
j'y crois pas du tout que je poste
alexandre champagne qu'il me disait
c'est l'astrologie comment la connaît
comme basé sur un calendrier décalé d'un
mois fait tout ce qu'on pense qu'on est
on est comme un mois côté les signes
astrologiques
c'est sur les signes astrologiques ce
qui réfère à quelque chose de 3000 1
mais il ya eu un décalage une allemande
et un décalage de l'axé de rotation de
la tourelle en fait tu connais comme
quoi vraiment notre signe astrologique
c'est quand tu regardes limiteront à moi
j'ai tellement un capricorne qu'elle
n'en était pas vraiment j'ai fait une bd
sur l'astrologie c'est à la bezole parce
que mon site s'était aussi de santé
temps en temps je me fais plaisir je
parle des d'autres sujets de l'année
passée j'ai fait ce n'est pas possible
c'est cette année que je suis mais
récemment d'année en année je vais te
bénisse l'astrologie puis j'ai pris
toutes les enfants puis toutes les
choses d'autres les toutes les grandes
et les grands principes en astrologie se
déconstruisent très facilement à la
lumière des informations scientifiques
celui qui me fait le plus rire le sait
mercure rétrograde n'avait entendu sept
haut-parleurs
non ok puis j'ai entendu termes
juridiques et sa vie et celle de ses
belfort qui moi je le vois passer ces
réseaux se souder fois l'idée de mer que
tu as et une mercure ouais je pense et
mercure rétrograde c'est que dans le
fond quand tu regardes dans le ciel il
ya une période de l'année où la planète
mercure à l'avant salle avance à
l'avancé des hawks à la loi de recul un
petit enfant après avoir reculé par
conteneurs rétrograde dans le sens comme
si mercure ramené à l'arête pied recul
et les gens qui croient à mercurey
programme en fait d'un gain qui croise
ce qu'ils disent ce qu'ils disent que
c'est une période de fortes
perturbations énergétique que je sais
pas trop quoi ils disent que c'est là
que tout les malheurs qui arrive une
période très intense et le souhait des
accidents c'est la petite chicane avec
des amis etc
et quand tu regardes ça quand tu
regardes ou tout simplement d'un point
de vue
mais astrophysique c'est que c'est une
illusion d'optique en réalité ainsi que
dans le fond la planète à la planète
mercure à la notation est rendu au bout
puis enlevé à huawei en fait ces atomes
dans une direction mais nous aussi on
tourne fait que c'est sûr que des fois
pendant que nous on tourne la planète
comme des fois ça peut donner des
affaires fauqué dans le ciel sont pas
avoir l'impression que la planète est
est en train de reculer
en réalité c'est juste qui est en train
de virer dans un axe qui pas la même que
le nom moi j'ai fait pour ceux qui
veulent lire là dessus j'ai fait un
dessin dans ma bd pour expliquer sommet
mais ça s'explique nous n'aurions rien
expliqué mais là les gens fassent comme
louis commencé à ce moment là que je me
fais tout le temps je prends tout le
temps mes clés pendant mercure et rocard
bus comme biais de confirmation juste
d'assister aux petits partis ou tu
remarques tout le takao c'est sûr mais
c'est une prophétie auto-réalisatrice
166,6 et mercurey 3 g fait pendant ces
périodes sur marc toutes les merdes qui
t'arrive
viapresse était comme fou on est sortis
de mercure et trop gras depuis l'aube et
aride les mêmes enfants
je pense vraiment que mercure et
regardons remplacé vendredi stratus
aujourd'hui quelqu'un me parlerait de
rentrer a dit rice je trouve vraiment
qu'il use up mais quelqu'un parle de
métaux rétrograde y est quasiment cool
au monde de la mode est aux pubs ste
ouais mais tu vois c'est maintenant moi
je trippe sur certains autres c'est de
la fiction je serai plus là dessus et
puis je me dis si tu sais que c'est de
la fiction puis ça t'intéresse rafale
fin mai les demandes qui croit dur comme
fer
si mélo josh kalis et jaune et musique
avec mon amie amélie protelos aux restos
après avec une de ses amies qui sont
tombés au golf tout souhaité tout ce qui
vient avec ses pieds son bain astrologie
tim peel et ont parlé d'être sopi le i7
est elle assez notamment où je me situe
par rapport à ceux c'est ainsi que je te
plutôt catésien puis que j'embarque pas
là-bas pileux les deux se mettent à
parler d'eux sauf que moi je suis comme
un peu déconnecté
il a alors posé des questions en bout de
ligne ils finissent par comme avouer que
il croit pas vraiment ouais mais que
tu es aimé ton ami liam dit betty
mettons mais tant qu un tel fait ce jeu
mais dit
normalement ça me go serait je me dis oh
c'est son côté j'aime son côté gémeaux
et ça m'aide à l'accepter je me dis faut
que j'accepte les gémeaux comme qui sont
toutes j'accepte les vagues a dit dans
le fond c'est juste une manière de
d'accepter les gens comme qui sont puis
elle s'est ainsi comme ce que c'est y
apportent ces faits qu'à croire quelque
chose de fictionnelle pièce as d'y
croire pour vrai mais pas par la réalité
et croient pas vraiment pauvre aimé que
ça il y apporte un petit peu d'empathie
ou de genre de connaissance de soi et
des autres
comment est ce que je veux je comprend
100 % puis quand j'ai fait ma bd j'ai
interviewé une fille qui jeta brillante
parfaite qui l'a doit à peu près 20 même
durant trois ans le thé dans les âges
beaucoup aussi très très fort
l'astrologie ans morin qui a mis à peu
près la même affaire et ramsey si ça
m'intéresse comme dans mes champs
d'intérêt mais je peux pas dire que je
crois que tant que ça mais c'est comme
si c'est quelque chose qui m'inspire de
ceux ci va commander ça devient
quasiment plus comme une sorte de ces
même pas une philosophie tu sais comme
une source d'inspiration un peu
s'intéressent à sauter comme moi quand
j'étais jeune le cache de ben je tripais
sur le tarot t il ya quelque chose que
je trouve pas encore aujourd'hui tout ce
fascinant le taraude il ya quelque chose
là donc je trouve que ça ça révèle
quelque chose sur la psyché humaine tu
peux tirer n'importe quelle carte puis
la personne va se mettre à parler plein
d'enfants l'astrologie c'est un peu la
même chose et comme une occasion pouvoir
discuter de nos personnalités ou de
réfléchir à cette personne est un peu
comme ça pourquoi ça me fait penser à
telle autre personne mais est un peu
différent je pense est assez généralisé
comme une espèce de mauvais chemin pour
réfléchir sur l'humain wyplay en fait
oui puis celle à la france et que la
plupart des gens par contre qu'ils
croisent se croient ou croient pas ou
qui très plat dessus ils vont te dire ça
peut pas faire de mal à personne et ce
je suis tellement désaccord dans qu'est
ce que ça peut faire mal
ça peut faire mal à plusieurs niveaux
mais mettons jeune homme double
premièrement il ya des grosses business
en ce moment qu'ils vendent un paquet de
bébés el hadj mais on y vend des pierres
de neptune des inférieurs puis toutes
sortes de gosse le le marché des
bébelles ésotérique lepidi des bâtons
pour faire de la magie blanche
depi nan c'est pas des jobs celui des
pyramides énergétique tout seul lewiston
il ya eu des cristaux il ya un boom sur
instagram fait qu'il ya une industrie
qui se bâtit autour de tissu avec des
jeux et du monde qui font profiter d'eux
je trouve ça triste
la deuxième affaire c'est que ça nuit à
la culture scientifique populaire tiens
je dire si tu refuse d'accepter un
moment donné que tous les principes de
l'astrologie ne repose sur rien qu'ils
sont même en contradiction avec tous
concernent astrophysique puisque malgré
ce tu choisi de continuer à croire des
enfants qui n'ont pas de bon sens comme
ça ça peut pas t'aider
je gare aux états unis on fait un
sondage aux etats unis une couple
d'années ne qui disaient que je pense à
un américain sur trois est pas au
courant là dessus c'est la terre qui
tourne autour du soleil ou l'inversé
plus à nous découvrir
mais à côté de son soudain l'astrologie
ça fait pas de mal c'est tout le même
paquet d'affaires
moi je pense que on devrait on devrait
s'inquiéter de l'impact que ça sur la
culture scientifique populaire on veut
rehausser le niveau on veut pas la bce
puis pour moi c'est un peu comme un fail
de l'éducation scientifique
à l'école j'étais obligé de le voir
comme ceux malheureusement juge pas les
gens croient ça mais je pense je pense
que je devrais peut-être s'informer un
peu plus tout à fait ça me fait c'est un
tout ph tu disais je pense
qu'éventuellement la la science pour
tout expliquer régis comme hp était dans
le domaine de la connaissance objective
c'est quand même des choses si je te
demande qu'est ce que le courage
l'olivier et aucune île rien de
scientifique pour répondre sinon parce
que c'est pas une question science est
purement subjectif c'est une question à
mon avis qui est une question de
vocabulaire
ouais c'est quoi le courage puis le
document on va sortir dans un débat
sémantique c'est sur c'est quoi le
courage j'ai l'impression que non mais
je veux répondre à une question
scientifiquement ce une question
scientifique
non oui mais mettons que je demande
c'est quoi la moto doit un footeux pop
tu vas pouvoir me répondre en termes
scientifiques parlement c'est-à-dire en
termes de commandes this is equal et
l'ailé il fait rarement dans l'action
qu'est ce qui se passe dans le cerveau
qu'est ce que c'est pas tout ça mais ça
va pas expliquer ça va pas sarr pas la
même réponse que je demande un poète
c'est quoi l'amour
me répond en termes émotionnel ou un thé
qu'on pratique il ya plusieurs niveaux
de connaissance d'un jeune homme même
chose cet accord vise pas la même
question si tu me demande c'est quoi
l'amour - la main probablement que si je
te demander si tu veux savoir quoi tu
veux savoir qu'est ce qui se passe dans
mon cerveau quand j'en amour peut savoir
que cela me fait me sentir moins ceux ci
c'est comme si ta question c'est ben
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on sent domaine
qu'on est en amont le score nettement je
sais pas si je faisais ce n'est pas une
question scientifique tant les questions
scientifiques on peut il répondre quand
ils sont formulés et puis moi d'accord
avec toi d'être leader dame je pense
dans mon livre au jeu le dixième année
j'ai dit que tout toute question peut
être adressé scientifiquement si on la
formule d'une bonne ambiance comme si
quelqu'un dit moi je crois un dieu à
tête de chèvre
je peux pas répondre à cette qpc
typiquement par contre il dit je crois
un dieu à tête de cherves qui m'a aidé à
gagner au poker
ah ok mais là tout ça se vérifie je peux
aller à téteghem de poker je peux
tchéquie quand est-ce que tu quand tout
va mieux quand est ce que ton du
attaques de cherves et éloquente est ce
qu était pas là on va faire une
expérience à double aveugle l'on peut
répondre mais c'est juste dans la façon
que tout oppose et tient vraiment à dieu
cf qu'il a dû renoncer à tout le monde
ce succès si vous suivez pas barré
encore du mal mais tu vois dans ton
exemple de dire c'est quoi le courage
sur quel courage selon la définition de
cas en ce moment sur moment où est-ce
que j'ai du courage mettons ont chaud
que ça peut être ça peut être expliquer
c'est quoi la norme nc koala c'est quoi
le nom fait ressentir
qu'est-ce qui commence equal c'est quoi
les faits sur ton cerveau de sentir
honoré trois ports les mesures est monté
s'explique pas vraiment c'est quoi
l'honneur sa salle explique cela
explique le sentiment qu tort explique
les mécanismes s'explique l'espèce de
chimie notre cerveau mais s'explique pas
c'est quoi le concept universel de la
norme étant moi même et mes mais ça
c'est à dire que c'est des questions
philosophiques que tu utilises enseigne
la philosophie sacem est de réfléchir
sur les concepts le demande c'est quoi
le nord qu'est ce qui définit le nord
c'est de la philosophie les questions
philosophiques ne sont pas toutes des
questions scientifiques c'est comme par
exemple pourquoi on existe c'est quoi le
but
la vie y'a pas de réponse scientifique à
100 c'est m'expliquer pourquoi on est
ici en ce moment tout on vient d'où on
vient on peut remonter au big bang on
peut dire comment on a été créé mais
pourquoi on n'existait pas une question
scientifique est de lui qu on ne peut
pas répondre à toutes les questions
scientifiques et des questions de
philosophie qui sont hyper intéressant
si tu veux te demander c'est quoi le
courage puisqu à l'honneur je sais que
c'est super intéressant
philosophiquement mais pour moi ce n'est
pas une question scientifique cissé
savoir ce qui se passe dans ton cerveau
je peux prendre un petit gant de fer
d'imagerie fonctionnelle dans ton
cerveau voir quelles sont ces allumés
pour moi de faire ce chignon puisse
battre face à saint-andré c'est exact ça
serait très prétentieux mais mais ce
sens on peut faire ça mais ça répondra
pas à ta question
c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
vraiment succès puis ça une autre chose
aussi qui m'allume dans ce que tu dit
toutefois ouverte la question en disant
moi j'aime beaucoup le seigneur des
anneaux que j'aime beaucoup la science
fiction puis c'est comme si pour moi ce
n'est pas de la science je me suis que
cet univers là dans ma tête en même
temps que la science a co existent tout
à fait mais mais mais encore là ces deux
univers qui sont pas incompatibles
souvent les gens vont dire ce que tu
crois tu t'es tu aimes le système le
thème star wars mais en même temps dit
elle à partie et en fait j'ai interviewé
une de mes idoles ya peu près deux
semaines qui s'appelle est un urologue
qui s'appelle steven nos valeurs c'est
probablement la personne dans le monde
que la grande influence sur ce que je
fais en vrai et il me dit une phrase qui
était malade mental jodie qui fait
toujours un effort il déploie de grands
efforts pour séparer sa pensée
scientifique de son ce que ça veut dire
c'est que pour lui dans sa famille très
clair que quand on est en train de se
divertir n'est pas dans un univers
irrationnel qui a pas besoin de se
demander ça existe des fusils laser ou
si ça existe d d d d d d un bâton de
gandalf qui s'allument dit où est cet
héros de ces faits que je pense qu'à un
moment donné si ce que tu disais tantôt
tu sais que la science va répondre à
toutes les questions
je pense que la science vise à répondre
à toutes les questions scientifiques
après ça c'est un effort qu'on peut se
poser un paquet d'autres questions que
ion seront pas obligés d'avoir une
réponse dans le fond car j'étais jeune
j'avais genre d'esprit scientifique je
fais des expériences pire
gomis est cotée à partir du cégep que le
gîte en musique que ça a été comme les
autres les en lisant les emplois
j'écoutais ce christ cet homme
intéressant puis domaine - il ya tant de
choses à savoir l'esprit crise et que
c'est donc important qu'ils le jeu tomb
ait une espèce de spirale vertueuse en
fait le t2 amené à noter ici tellement
l'fun vraiment le fun quand qui tenait à
comprendre un peu plus ce qui est
développé dans un esprit critique c'est
moi c'est vraiment le feu tirant de
rendre la science populaire si c'est une
des choses les plus difficiles parce la
science est aride
c'est compliqué tout cela fait que
souvent les gens ils vont diront à la
science pour mon affaire à moins 6 mois
alors que vous auriez tout rejoint par
cela tourne tout un tas on a tout un
smartphone s'assimile à faire super
hyper scientifique et de la physique
quantique la boîte c'est fake là un gros
enjeu en vulgarisation c'est de rendre
ce intéressant c'est d'intéresser
l'annoncé se fait quand une personne
comme neil degrasse comme beloeil qui
réussissent à rejoindre un gros bassin
de personnes 40 sont intéressants il
faut absolument si je vous il faut
fouetter enthousiaste face aux soeurs
parce que c'est extrêmement difficile
tendent et très bon vulgarisateur de
niche mois qui vont s'adresser à un
petit groupe de dix vulgarisateur qui
parle juste à d'autres scientifiques
c'est petit ça c'est super mais de
parler à la masse et en ce moment c'est
ce dont on a besoin de parler à la masse
pour empêcher l'espèce de l'espèce de
tourbillon antiscientifique dans lequel
on est là bas ces gens là ils font
magnifiquement puis se met on en a
besoin
ces contrées qui est deux les deux
courants coexistent
c'est en fait les deux sont forts je
trouve que d'un côté on sent un intérêt
puis un appétit pour la science pour
explication le qui en même temps d'un
cours en un contre un contre courant ou
chantent mais pas aussi fort par contre
ça s'est bien terminé ce point là parce
qu'on entend souvent ce genre oh mon
dieu le sait rendu que les scientifiques
aient pu personnes s'étaient rendues
moitié-moitié le la moitié pour la
modique on est vraiment pologne dans
toutes les analyses dans tout les
sondages qui sont faits les
scientifiques il ceux qui y ont un très
haut niveau de confiance chez le public
le fait qu'il fait là
la grande majorité des gens font
confiance aux scientifiques pour leur
donner la bonne information et blablabla
je pense que ce qui donne l'impression
que le mot les mouvements anti science
aussi fort c'est qu'ils sont très très
sévèrement et c'est la minorité bruyante
où ils font ils sont très bonnes phases
du marketing sont très bons pour se
mettre en évidence entre maîtrise bien
les réseaux sociaux ils sont capables de
manipuler un peu les médias manipulent
et la politique maintenant si c'est ça
ils sont très fort là dessus je pense
que l'enjeu c'est que les scientifiques
eux ne sont pas habitués d'utiliser ce
genre d'outil lot son habitude et j'ose
dire leurs enfants qui sont allé
discrètement
ouais non peut plus se permettre de
faire ça en 2019 si je donne des
conférences je donne des conférences aux
scientifiques
puis je leur dis ça je le redis on n'est
pas le choix de devenir des militants
pour la science aujourd'hui puis j'aime
pas sur moi j'ai jamais eu envie d'être
militaire beau crier sinon je pense
qu'il veut c'est je pense le
scientifique où il souvent qu'ils soient
frileux je te demande d'aller sur la
sphère politique n'est vraiment pas ce
que c'est bien et c'est pas leur domaine
de 200 appartements dire sans
l'évocation lehoux qui ressemble à ce
que tout le monde de ski disposés à
aller parler sera pas place publique le
tpiy qui quitta la respecte ceux qui
n'ont pas le temps non pas le coup
traction par rapport au vrai travail des
scientifiques mais les scientifiques que
je connais et j'ai plein d'amis d'amis
j'ai plein de scientifiques de plein de
plein de domaines c'est tout dit c'est
des passionnés le sedif foule mais god
neuf de leurs enfants ils tripent sur ce
qu'ils font ces niches tout les gens qui
sont armés de la recherche de ses tripes
à fond
nous avons su vraiment comme trip est à
fond sur la recherche puis quand il
arrive chez eux
allez faire du militantisme
scientifiquement c'est sur facebook pis
phares bi tché pied et s'était retiré la
mention comme tchèque il faut choisir
mes combats - un médecin je fais de la
bonne médecine je viens chercher je fais
de la bonne recherche c'est ça ma
contribution s'est fait quand même je
peux 0 les blancs métis
c'est juste qu'à un moment donné ça va
prendre plus qu'ils disent ok ben comme
essayé de m'impliquer des initiatives
individuelles non ça sera pas suffisant
vraiment merci la pharmacie mais nicole
ça coince un grand rôle ça fait deux ans
jerry trois géants compris mais non mais
non mais non merci beaucoup d'être venus
et merci merci c'était vraiment cool
encore c'était super
c'est pas la dernière fois qu'est ce que
ça vient pour toi le prochainement
mettons ben moi je continue à écrire ma
saison quatre mois exactement ça va être
en ondes au mois de décembre
je travaille vraiment là-dessus
présentement si je prépare une coupe de
bd aussi pour mon site web cet automne
parce que c'est vraiment abandonné
mission d'ailleurs j'aime beaucoup cet
effet merci de me dire ce soit merci
beaucoup cool salut